[Musique]
Messieurs, bonsoir. Bonsoir. Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? On va
commencer par notre star Francis Perin.
La communauté t'adore tellement. Donc on
te donne la parole en premier. Bonsoir
et merci de l'invitation. Donc Francis
Perin, je travaille sur les questions
énergétiques, en particulier sous
l'angle économique et
géopolitique. Je suis directeur de
recherche à l'IRIS, l'Institut de
relation interale et stratégique qui est
basé à Paris et chercheur associé dans
un ftang comme on dit en bon français
basé à Rabat qui s'appelle le policy
center for venu south.
Philippe Charlais. Alors Philippe
Charlaise donc j'ai une grande
expérience et vie dans l'énergie
ingénieur des mines de formation. J'ai
fait 43 ans chez Total énergie. Je suis
retraité depuis peu et je j'animais
jusqu'à peu l'observatoire énergie
climat d'un autre ting tank qui
s'appelle l'Institut Sapiens.
Nicolas Millant. Moi, je suis ingénieur
de formation. J'ai été conseiller
scientifique pour France Stratégie sur
les sujets de transport et l'énergie et
aujourd'hui je vends des bases de
données sur les voitures électriques et
les culottes
menstruelles. C'est un
virage. Messieurs, on va on va essayer
de parler d'énergie géopolitique des
aussi des répercussions avec Philippe on
en parler des répercussions
démocratiques d'une carence en énergie
ou d'un sevrage
énergétique. On commence par quoi
Francis ?
Tu veux tu veux commencer avec quel
sujet ? On parle de la géopolitique. Je
te pose une question à la mort moelle.
Est-ce qu'on peut commencer à parler de
Donald Trump ? Si tu veux, vas-y. Par
exemple, parce que c'est quand même dans
l'actualité 2025, il y a quelque chose
qu'il y a maintenant qu'il n'y avait pas
avant, qui change beaucoup de choses
évidemment dans le monde puisqu'on parle
de la première puissance mondiale et
d'un homme un petit peu original. Et
c'est aussi le cas dans le monde de
l'énergie puisqu'on a un président, donc
son 2e mandat qui vient avec des idées
très fortes sur l'énergie, la place de
l'énergie dans l'économie américaine,
dans l'économie mondiale, qui soutient à
fond les énergies fossiles, pétrole,
charbon, gaz
naturel, qui n'est pas un très grand fan
des énergies
renouvelables et pas du tout un grand
fan de l'éolien et du solaire. Bon, il
est pas contre hydroélectricité,
biocarburant, géothermie, mais bon euh
par contre les énergies intermittentes,
c'est pas du tout sa tasse de thé. Qui
sort une nouvelle fois de l'accord de
Paris dès qu'il met un pied à la Maison
Blanche le 20 janvier 2025 euh qui euh
dérèglemente à tout va dans le secteur
de l'énergie et qui a quelques idées
clés qui sont il faut produire plus
d'énergie aux États-Unis, des urgences
énergétiques. Tout à fait. Dès le 20
janvier, il signe des dizaines de
décrets. Tout le monde a cette image en
tête. Il est dans le bureau oval, il a
plein de décrets sur son bureau
présidentiel. Là-dessus, signe cinq
décrets sur l'énergie dont l'un porte le
nom effectivement pour une urgence
énergétique. Donc ce qui montre un petit
peu l'importance de ce sujet à ses yeux.
Et donc il veut produire que l'on
produise plus d'énergie aux États-Unis,
notamment d'énergie fossiles pour faire
baisser les prix de l'énergie de façon
importante parce que ce sera bon pour le
consommateur américain, pour l'industrie
américaine, pour l'économie américaine.
Premier point. Deuxème point, il veut se
servir de l'énergie comme une arme de
domination. Le programme de Donald Trump
sur l'énergie n'a pas changé d'une
virgule depuis 2016. Donc on peut pas
dire qu'on éétait pas au courant. Et ça
se résume en une phrase, d'abord
l'indépendance énergétique, ensuite la
domination énergétique. Et il met ça en
œuvre. En février, il crée un conseil
national de la domination énergétique.
Ça ça s'invente pas. Je connais beaucoup
dans le monde de conseil national de
l'énergie. Il y en a qu'un qui s'appelle
Conseil national de la domination
énergétique. C'est Trump, il l'avait
annoncé, il le fait. Il a sans doute
plein de défauts, mais il a en tout cas
une qualité, c'est qu'il est assez il
est pas hypocrite, il est assez franc du
collier. Et donc il veut pousser à la
hausse la production d'énergie
américaine et mondiale, notamment
d'énergie fossile, notamment de pétrole.
il accorde une grande place au pétrole
énergie numéro 1, il faut quand même le
rappeler hein. Euh donc il veut pousser
l'industrie pétrolière américaine à
produire plus en déréglementant
massivement sur le plan environnemental,
en offrant plus de permis à l'industrie
pour qu'elle puisse travailler sur les
terres fédérales et dans l'offshore
américain. Et il pousse les pays de ce
qu'on appelle l'OPEP et l'OPEP plus.
Donc l'OPEP organisation des pays
exportateurs de pétrole 12 pays. OPEP
plus 22 pays exportateurs de pétrole. Il
fait pression sur eux notamment sur
l'Arabie Saoudite pour qu'il produisent
plus pour faire baisser les prix. Donc
ça déménage à Washington et comme c'est
Washington, ça déménage pour le monde
entier. Évidemment,
je rebondis sur ce que tu viens de dire.
Les Européens, est-ce que tu discutes
avec eux ? Du moins ceux en charge de
l'énergie, comment ils perçoivent ça ?
Est-ce qu'ils sont en panique ? Est-ce
qu'il ils se ils se sortent un petit peu
les ils se dépêchent de rattraper ?
Est-ce qu'ils ont fait l'évaluation de
la capacité de production européenne en
gig par rapport à aux États-Unis, par
rapport à la Chine ? Et est-ce qu'il se
disent voilà bah c'est un peu compliqué,
les États-Unis sont déjà bien
exportateurs. Nous, on produit que 1600
GW. Nos capacités c'est 1600 GW dans
toute l'Europe à la louche. Les Chinois,
c'est environ 3000 GW.
Est-ce que les Européens se réveillent
du côté de l'Europe, disons l'Union
européenne ? Il y a une part de de
cidération, une part de panique. Et la
cidération en fait, elle ne n'est pas
vraiment justifiée puisque on sait
depuis des années ce que Trump veut
faire en général et dans le domaine de
l'énergie en particulier. Sur différents
domaines, il a pu faire des virages à
180°, pas sur l'énergie.
Son programme est le même depuis 2016
sans changement d'une virgule. Donc si
on ne se mettait pas la tête dans le
sable, ce qu'on fait souvent en Europe,
on devrait pas au minimum être surpris.
On peut ne pas aimer, c'est une autre
chose, mais pas être surpris. Donc on
est surpris, on est un petit peu
paniqué. On essaie de sauver la COP 30
qui aura lieu cet automne à Bellem au
Brésil. Euh et la COP 30, c'est 30.
C'est plus important que 27 parce que
c'est 30, c'est un chiffre rond.
Premièrement, euh ça l'esprit humain,
c'est un petit peu ça. Et puis aussi,
plus sérieusement, même si j'étais quand
même sérieux tout à l'heure, euh c'est
le 10e anniversaire de l'accord de Paris
2015, COP 21 Fus. Euh donc tout à fait
absolument. Donc on attend quand même
beaucoup de la COP 30, mais une COP 30
avec la première puissance mondiale qui
se retire complètement de toutes les
négociations climatiques, qui dit ça ça
m'intéresse pas, ça je m'en moque, je
n'en tiens absolument pas compte. Bon
courage à nos amis brésiliens pour
organiser et faire un succès de la COP
30. Philippe Charles ? Oui. Donc moi je
dirais que pour rebondir et je suis tout
à fait d'accord avec tout ce que disait
tout disait Francis, la première chose
c'est que je crois que Trump signe
définitivement la mort de l'espoir
multilatéraliste qui était issu de la
chute du mur de Berlin. Alors on savait
déjà que le monde multilatéraliste avait
beaucoup de plombs dans l'aile. Mais
disons que Trump définitivement celle la
fin du monde multilatéraliste avec
maintenant une logique de trois blocs.
Le bloc des bricks, le bloc européen et
le bloc américain avec évidemment une
prise de distance très nette par rapport
par rapport à l'Europe. Alors que si on
remonte à avant le la chute du mur de
Berlin, on avait en fait deux blocs,
c'était plus lisible et plus facile. Et
donc je dirais que l'impasse dans
laquelle se trouve et on y reviendra
actuellement la transition énergétique,
je pense que c'est un des premiers
facteur tout à fait structurant du fait
de cet impasse, c'est que évidemment il
était beaucoup plus facile de faire une
transition énergétique qui a était
encore
l'espoir existant lors de la de lors de
la COP 21. Alors que contrairement euh à
la situation actuelle, on est vraiment
rentré dans un dans un monde dans un
monde de logique de bloc qui euh
pénalise énormément l'avenir de cette
transition énergétique.
Nicolas, pourquoi euh je vais je vais
répondre d'après d'abord, tu veux
peut-être juste sur les Européens et
après j'écouterai ta question. Mais tu
es magnifique ce soir sur euh Trump. Je
pense qu' il regarde il regarde souvent.
Il a compris que il avait besoin d'une
électri d'une énergie sa femme qui
regarde sa femme d'une énergie abondante
et bon marché. Ça les Européens ils ont
pas compris. Donc Trump son objectif
c'est relancer vice-président c'est
relancer l'économie avec une énergie pas
chère, du pétrole pas cher, du gaz pas
cher, électricité pas cher. Les
Européens leur objectif c'est sauver la
planète en étant neutre en carbone en
2050. Donc c'est pas le même prisme de
lecture. Les Européens ont toujours pas
compris malgré la crise de l'inflation
2022 qu'on avait besoin d'une énergie
abondante et bon marché pour pouvoir
exister. Euh donc malheureusement, ils
peuvent pas comprendre ce que fait Trump
et eux ils restent convaincus que en
installant des panneaux solaires, des
éoliennes partout, on va sauver la
planète. Bon, on va juste on va juste se
suicider. Très bien. Mais ça s'ouvre à
rien du tout. Non mais si si on fait
augmenter les gaz à effet de serre,
c'est aussi un suicide. Bon, pour
revenir à la question
principale, avec ce que Francis nous a
dit, avec ce que Philippe nous a dit, la
clé de lecture, le prisme de lecture,
c'est quoi ? C'est une course à
l'échelle haute énergétique pour
financer, du moins pardon euh arriver
à fournir suffisamment
d'électricité à l'intelligence
artificielle. C'est un comportement
prédateur d'où le Groenland, d'où d'où
les revendications de de Trump envers
des territoire bourré de ressources.
C'est quoi sa clé de lecture à votre
avis ? Et est-ce qu'il y a un conseil de
défense avec des énergéticiens au plus
haut de l'État ?
Bah une fois de plus euh pour eux c'est
très clair. Il a été élu pour relancer
l'économie euh américaine. Donc euh il
sait ce qu'il faut faire, c'est avoir
une énergie bon marché. Il fait le
nécessaire aux États-Unis, il fait le
nécessaire en Arabie Saoudite pour qu'il
fassent baisser les prix en augmentant
leur production. et il fait même le
nécessaire en Europe parce qu'il va
peut-être nous permettre de réimporter
du gaz russe bon marché à travers un des
Européens sont pas d'accord ça va pas
faire long feu hein oui alors c'est ça
qui est très marrant en ce moment entre
guillemets très marrant c'est qu'ils
viennent de signer en 2027 une une sorte
de al je dis en anglais en français une
en anglais c'est road map road map bref
une carte une carte une carte pour
sortir du se passer du gazus en 2027 et
pendant ce temps-là, les Américains
négocient avec la Russie pour pouvoir
relancer l'approvisionnement de l'Europe
pour qu'elle ait une électricité un gaz
bon marché et qu'elle puisse éviter
l'effondrement total. Francis, peut-être
une autre clé de lecture par rapport à
ce que nous évoquons maintenant.
Vous posiez tout à l'heure une question
sur l'état d'urgence énergétique de
Trump, donc décret signé dès le premier
jour à la Maison Blanche. Comment est-ce
qu'il justifie ça, lui et son
administration ? Façon très simple. Il
dit "Nous, les États-Unis, nous sommes
engagés dans une course avec la
République populaire de Chine pour
l'intelligence artificielle.
Ça va demander des quantités d'énergie,
notamment d'électricité énorme. Donc il
faut se mettre en ordre de bataille pour
gagner cette course contre la Chine pour
l'intelligence artificielle. Et pour ça,
il faut qu'on mette notre système
énergétique, notamment nos réseaux
électriques à niveau. Ils ne le sont
pas, il y a urgence parce que sinon
c'est les Chinois qui vont gagner. donc
estat d'urgence énergétique. Voilà la
justification des cris signé le 20
janvier 2025 par Donald Trump premier
jour à la Maison Blanche. Je pense
qu'une autre une autre justification
aussi, c'est que si les Américains
aujourd'hui un avantage compétitif
majeur par rapport aux Chinois, c'est
justement sur le gaz et le pétrole. Ça
fait pas l'ombre d'un doute. Euh les
Chinois euh sont très dépendants et
c'est vraiment le leur talon d'Achile
hein. Euh ils produisent environ 4
millions de baril jour et ils en et ils
en consomment 16 à 16 à 17. Donc ils
sont fortement importateurs de pétrole.
Oui. Sources. C'est quoi les sources de
ces chiffres ? Oh c'est le par de
l'énergie ou bien l'énergie Institute,
l'ancien BP Statistical Review. Donc
c'est on peut trouver ça assez
facilement. Et donc ce que je veux dire
c'est que il garde cet avantage
incontestable alors que dans toutes les
autres matières premières les Chinois
cassent complètement la baraque que ce
soit sur l'acier, l'aluminium, les métau
rares, le charbon et cetera. Par contre,
le gaz et le pétrole, ça reste quand
même quelque chose de très problématique
pour les Chinois. Il faut quand même
savoir que si on coulait deux à trois
gros pétroliers dans le fameux D3 de
Malaka, par où arrive une grosse partie
de la production du Moyen-Orient qui va
vers la Chine, on peut complètement
bloquer en en quelques heures l'économie
chinoise. Donc ça veut dire que c'est
vraiment les pines qu'ils ont dans le
pied et Trump l'a très bien compris. Et
donc je pense qu' s'il y a une
dépendance des Chinois qui veut essayer
d'exacerber, c'est sur le pétrole et le
gaz. et plus il produira de pétrole et
le gaz, plus il pourra exacerber cette
dépendance chinoise. Je complète sur la
sécurisation du collier de perle, ce qui
a motivé aussi les Chinois à faire la
route de la soie. Euh
absolument pour euh poursuivre sur ce
que disait Philippe sur l'avantage clé
des États-Unis par rapport aux
hydrocarbures, pétrole et gaz naturel.
Aujourd'hui, États-Unis, premier
producteur mondial de pétrole, premier
producteur mondial de gaz naturel,
premier exportateur mondial de gaz
naturel et à l'intérieur premier
exportateur mondial de gaz naturel
liquéfié, le fameux GNL dont on parle de
plus en plus. Ce gaz transporté par
bateau donc par métanhanier. Donc oui,
pour les hydrocarbures, c'est un grand
point fort de l'économie américaine et
de la puissance américaine parce que qui
dit énergie dit économie et aussi
puissance géopolitique évidemment. Et
surtout si on revient en
arrière dans les années 2000, jamais en
avant, on revient jamais en avant, c'est
vrai. Mais si on revient dans les années
2005 2006, à l'époque les Américains
sont dépendants à 70 % de leurs
importations pétrolières. Ouais, moi
j'avais même bon enfin 60 70 %.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils importent
massivement du pétrole alors
qu'aujourd'hui ils sont indépendants en
pétrole. Ils exportent du gaz et ils
commençaient à importer du gaz. Il faut
quand même savoir que tous les terminaux
de GNL qui ont été transformés en
terminaux de liquéfaction avait
initialement été pensé en terminaux de
regéification pour importer du gaz
naturel. Et donc les États-Unis devaient
être un importateur majeur de gaz
naturel liquéfié et il est devenu
aujourd'hui un exportateur majeur de gaz
liquéfié. Donc on voit le pouvoir que
les États-Unis ont pris dans ces deux
domaines qui sont évidemment
fondamentaux qui sont le gaz et le
pétrole. Nicolas, l'Europe dans tout ça
et les conseils de défense, est-ce qu'il
y a des des
énergéticiens qui conseillent
correctement euh nos élus
? Bah c'est une bonne question. Euh j'ai
pas je connais pas la liste parce qu'il
y a quand même beaucoup de comités
théodule hein. Il y en a d'ailleurs une
prolifération ces dernières années
euh sur l'énergie. Je connais les gens
que je connais et qui connaissent ce
sujet là mais il participent pas à ces
comités théodule. Donc une fois de plus
l'Europe c'est quand même un quelque
chose d'assez idéologique. On est plutôt
dans l'énergie se rapproche plus de la
religion que de la science. Euh et donc
c'est pour ça qu'on je pense qu'on va
dans des dans des mauvaises directions.
Euh aux États-Unis, je pense qu'ils ont
des ingénieurs. Le nouveau ministre, je
crois, a pas mal travaillé dans le dans
le secteur en Chine. En Chine, ils ont
aussi que des ingénieurs, hein. Tous les
dirigeants sont ingénieurs. En Europe,
les ingénieurs, on on les cherche. Mais
rappelons-nous en c'était en je pense en
2004, non, c'était durant la le mandat
de du fils Bouche. Mon vice-président
était Dick Cheny. Dick Chen avait été
auparavant le président d'Ali Burton qui
est une des grosses compagnies
pétrolières. Bon alors on peut
effectivement critiquer le lobby, le
machin et cetera mais enfin c'était au
moins quelqu'un qui connaissait le le
gaz et c'est c'est la raison pour
laquelle Patrick
Pouyané aurait probablement sa place en
ministre de l'énergie. Ce serait bonne
chose. Je pense pas que ça je pense pas
que ça
l'intéresse. Pourrait d'ailleurs faire à
la fois ministre de l'énergie des
affaires étrangères. A priori on lui a
souvent posé la question. Il a dit qu'il
préférait rester à la tête de totale
énergie que il trouvait son travail
passionnant. Et par rapport à
l'actualité immédiate Donald Trump se
rend au
Moyen-Orient et il se rend en Arabie
Saoudite, Émirat arabe un
Qatar. Trois pays pétroliers et gaziers.
Le Qatar étant plus gazier que pétrolier
mais étant aussi un pays pétrolier. Deux
d'entre eux, Arabie Saoudite et Émir
Arabie, étant membre de l'OPEP et de
l'OPEP plus et le Qatar étant le 3è
exportateur mondial de gaz naturelfié
après États-Unis et
Australie. Donc l'énergie, alors il n'y
aura pas que l'énergie dans ce voyage de
Trump. On va évidemment parler Iran, on
va parler Gaza. Bon, il y a il y a plein
de sujets. Les sujets ne manquent pas au
Moyen-Orient, c'est clair
malheureusement parce qu'ils sont
souvent tragiques. Mais il est clair
qu'il y aura une forte odeur d'énergie
et d'hydrocarbure sur cette visite du
président américain au Moyen-Orient.
C'est intéressant ce que tu dis
Francis. Quand il y a de l'énergie en
général, il y a des conflits.
Il peut y avoir quelques lien Ouais.
pour le dire diplomatiquement et et pas
diplomatiquement, on formulerait ça
comment ? L'énergie c'est un enjeu
stratégique pour le monde. L'énergie
c'est ce qui fait trop le moteur
économique mondial. Donc c'est ce que
n'a pas compris Bruno Lomer peut-être.
Alors pour n'importe quel état,
l'énergie c'est stratégique. Euh pour
Bruno Lemer,
alors je ne vais pas rentrer
dans la critique de Bruno Lomer, mais
c'est un point absolument essentiel.
Nicolas l'évoquait. Est-ce que dans les
plusieurs pays européens, est-ce qu'on a
suff est-ce qu'on est suffisamment
conscient du poids stratégique du
secteur énergétique ? Point
d'interrogation. Plusieurs points
d'interrogation. Ben manifestement non.
Je vais prendre un exemple assez simple,
c'est que euh le Surinam et euh la
Guyane, le Guyana, le Guyana, pardon,
euh ont découvert offshore d'énormes
réserves de pétrole. Euh, euh je pense
que le Surinam est pas loin de
produire 250000 baril jour de baril.
Oui, oui. C'est donc c'est des réserves
absolument considérables produit plus de
600000 baril par jour. 600000 baril
jour. Voyez, j'étais j'étais j'étais
bien en dessous et euh il y a une
prolongation des champs offshore qui
passe par la Guyane française où
effectivement l'exploration pétrolière
est interdite depuis le
le la loi de 2017 votée par Nicolas
Hullot. Donc ce qui signifie
qu'aujourd'hui euh la France euh refuse
de regarder si elle a des hydrocarbures
parce que hydrocarbure égale diable
absolu euh alors que les deux pays
voisins en exploitent de même que le
Brésil, ce sont des champs en offshore
en grande profondeur d'eau euh qui
pourrait être tout à fait tout à fait
intéressant. D'ailleurs, je crois
personnellement que si la France avait
produit 2 millions de baril jour en
2017, je crois que la loi ne serait
jamais passée. Cette loi adoptée fin
2017 par le Parlement français prévoit
que l'État français ne peut plus
attribuer de nouveaux permis
d'exploration. En France métropolitaine
et tout l'outre mer français dont il
faut rappeler que c'est le deuxè au
monde en terme de superficie. Alors,
c'est un choix politique, hein, on en
pense ce qu'on veut, mais euh est-ce que
vraiment dans ce domaine maritime
immense, il y a pas d'hydrocarbure
quelque part ? Don la Guyane, j'ai un
peu de mal à le penser personnellement.
Nicolas, ça fait partie des de nos de
nos petites contradictions de notre jeu
du double standard qui fait qu'on a
quand même été plusieurs fois principal
importeur de gaz de chiste américain que
dans le GNL américain importé c'est à
peu près 2/ tiers de de gaz de chiste et
que qu'on interdit ça qu'on interdit ça
chez nous. Donc c'est que c'est
on interdit de non seulement de produire
mais pas de consommer et d'apporter.
Voilà. Et puis on interdit de regarder
aussi si euh le de le de le de le gaz
naturel liquéfié américain est fait
essentiellement à partir de gaz de chist
puisque la production actuelle de gaz
américain est à 80 %. Il y a encore un
petit peu de gaz naturel traditionnel
mais c'est surtout du gaz de chiste.
Donc c'est-à-dire qu'on ne peut pas
explorer, on ne peut même pas aller
regarder. En France ça n'est même pas
exploité. qu'on ne peut même pas
explorer parce que explorer sous-entend
qu'on pourrait trouver et si on trouve
on pourrait exploiter. Et donc c'est
interdit aujourd'hui. Alors là c'est pas
par la loi de 2017, c'est c'était la loi
Jacob si je me souviens en c'est 2010 ou
2011 quelque chose comme ça. Qui
interdit donc qui interdit ça mais par
contre on importe on est le premier
importateur de gaz naturel liquéfié
américain qui est du gaz de chiste. On
ne consomme pas tout, on en envoie une
partie, enfin le regifie et on envoie
une partie en Allemagne puisque les
Allemands eux n'ont jamais voulu
construire de de terminaux de de
regéification. Oui. Un autre problème
qu'on a aussi en Europe, c'est que comme
donc je reviens à la neutralité carbone,
quand on veut faire des contrats
d'approvisionnement gaz naturel, quand
par exemple le Qatar veut veut consigne
des contrats, en fait, il faisait des
engagements dans la durée puisque lui il
a des investissements importants. Donc
c'est des investiss engagement à 25 ans,
mais 2025 + 25 ça fait 2050 donc ça fait
neutralité carbone. Euh et donc euh donc
on va se refuser de signer euh ces
contrats et ce qui fait qu'en fait le
marché européen de l'énergie grosso modo
en Europe, on est passer de contrats qui
étaient plutôt sur le long terme à des
contrats qui sont de plus en plus sur le
court terme, voir sur parfois des sprot,
des bateaux de genel. Et qu'est-ce que
ça fait ça ? Ben, ça fait euh on
augmente notre exposition à la
volatilité des prix. Euh et ça qui c'est
ça qui peut créer un gros problème parce
que je le répète euh assez
régulièrement, la crise de l'inflation,
le premier domino qui est tombé euh en
avril mai 2021, c'est l'augmentation du
prix du gaz naturel. C'était avant la
guerre en Ukraine. Euh et c'est ça qui
par effet dominau sur les engrais, sur
l'électricité et cetera a amené à ces 15
voinflation et le fait qu'on a atteint
un record de baisse de consommation que
ce soit en France ou en Europe. Par
électricité aussi. On va venir sur
l'électricité. Alors si j'ai bien
compris, on se tire une balle dans le
pied dans les deux pieds dans les deux
mains. On se met une cagoule et on a les
deux pieds dans le ciment. Enfin, c'est
une des premières balles dans le pied,
on s'en tire plusieurs. On va y venir.
Et disons que c'est la première, c'est
effectivement C'est quoi les autres
balles ? Oh bah les autres balles, on
verra. on verra sur les renouvelables,
sur le nucléaire, sur l'électricité, sur
les batteries, sur les voitures, sur les
logements, enfin il y en a euh qui ont
une liste à rallonge aujourd'hui. Juste
pour revenir sur ce que disait Nicolas
sur le Qatar qui est important, euh les
dirigeants du Qatar nous disent "Voulez
du gaz, du gaz naturel liquéfié
? Nous, on veut vendre avec des contrats
de long terme. Ça nous donne une
visibilité. On investit des sommes
énormes. Le Qatar a récem dans les
dernières années lancé de nouveaux
développements gaziers sur un champ
gigantesque sous-marin qui est partagé
entre le Qatar et l'Iran qui est l'un
des plus gros champs gaziers du monde,
le Norfield. Euh coût des
investissements entre 40 et 50 milliards
de dollars. Quand on investit des sommes
de cet ordre-là, évidemment, on préfère
signer des contrat de long terme. Et les
Européens, pour les raisons qu'indiquit
Nicolas, disent "Attention, il faut pas
que ça dépasse 2050 puisque 2050
neutralité carbone." Alors, l'émire du
Qatar nous dit "Ben écoutez, moi je vais
aller vers les marchés asiatiques." Eux,
ils me posent pas de problème que la la
coupure de
2050. Euh donc, c'est un élément tout à
fait important à prendre en
considération. puisque nous sommes au
Moyen-Orient, si je puis dire pas ici,
mais puisque nous parlions du
Moyen-Orient, le voyage de Trump et
cetera, euh qu'est-ce qu'on nous dit en
Arabie Saoudite ?
Que nous dit par exemple le patron de
Saou Ramko, le géant pétrolier mondial
Amine Nasser, il nous dit "Vous parlez
de transition
énergétique, je ne la vois pas, je vois
une addition
énergétique. Actuellement, le
développement des énergies renouvelables
principalement solaires éolien ne fait
pas reculer la consommation mondiale
d'énergie fossiles qui continue à
augmenter. Donc, on continue, le monde
continue à consommer plein d'énergie
fossile et même un peu plus. et on
ajoute quelque chose, on empile. Donc
nous dit-il, c'est une addition
énergétique, ce n'est pas une transition
énergétique sur le plan des fêtes
aujourd'hui. Il a parfaitement raison
factuellement. Euh enfin moi le le mon
expérience personnelle, je suis rentré
dans le dans l'industrie pétrolière en
1982 et en 1982, les fossiles c'était 87
% du mix énergétique mondial.
Aujourd'hui, c'est 82 % mais avec une
quantité d'énergie qui a doublé. Donc ce
qui veut dire que globalement on a
doublé la consommation d'énergie fossile
et chaque année on bat les records de
consommation de gaz, de pétrole et de
charbon. Et euh les prospectives
montrent que ça va encore continuer
pendant pendant quelques années. C'est
quoi quelques années ? Oh, tu seras déjà
mort ou Oh, j'espère que non. Mais
disons que je ne vois pas les
consommations de pétrole euh et de gaz
diminuer et même de charbon diminué au
cours des 10 prochaines années. Après
euh inchallah
bah je pense que c'est un point un point
très important. C'est vrai que la
transition énergétique
bullshit c'est des éléments de langage.
C'est
quoi communication ? Mais c'est l'Europe
l'Europe est convaincue qu'elle est
engagée dans cette transition
énergétique. Mais c'est là que dans les
faits alors peut-être qu'elle l' un peu
plus que les autres région effectivement
mais ce qu'il faut regarder c'est ce qui
se passe aussi au niveau mondial. Les
émissions de CO2 bah ça c'est quand même
plutôt un problème au niveau mondial
qu'un problème au niveau local. Donc euh
et effectivement depuis que depuis que
on a fait les premières conférences des
partis, les émissions de CO2 n'ont
jamais augmenté aussi vite. Euh elles
n'ont jamais euh là chaque année, on bat
des records. Donc 2024 c'était encore un
nouveau record notamment sur le charbon.
Et pourquoi quelle est la la vraie
raison de cet histoire là ?
Ben presque concomitamment, on a eu la
Chine qui a rejoint l'OMC en décembre
2021 et donc on a 20 % 2001 2001 2001
pardon 2001 merci Francis et donc on a
20 % des usines mondiales qui sont
passées des pays de l'OCDE des pays
riches d'Occident à la Chine l'Inde et
les pays en voie développement donc on
est passé nos usines en France qui
fonctionnaient avec de en partie de
l'électricité nucléaire elles sont
partis au charbon. Donc c'est pas
tellement choquant que effectivement les
émissions de CO2 continuent à augmenter.
Et c'est vraiment là que j'appelle ça
l'éléphant dans la pièce, c'est qu'en
fait nous en France, on est très beau
sur la photo. Quand on regarde nos
émissions de CO2, elles ont baissé
presque de moitié dans l'industrie.
Cocorico, bah Cocorico. Alors oui, bien
sûr, il y a des il y a l'amélioration de
l'efficacité énergétique, très bien.
Mais il y a aussi beaucoup d'usines qui
ferment et qui s'en vont. Et donc si
c'est le plan de l'Europe aujourd'hui ou
le plan de de mes copains escristes de
fermer toutes les usines pour de fermer
toutes les usines pour euh pour pouvoir
fabser les émissions de CO2, ben
j'aimerais qu'on ait un autre plan parce
que ça c'est pas bon. En 2024, le monde
n'a jamais consommé autant de pétrole,
autant de charbon, autant de gaz naturel
dans toute l'histoire de
l'humanité. Alors est-ce qu'une fonction
exponentielle ? Non. Alors ça augmente
doucement, ça fait pas des bons, mais ça
continue encore à augmenter. On n'est
pas
arrivé à un plateau ou un pic comme
c'est différent mais enfin bon à un
sommet et on n'est certainement pas en
train de décliner puisqu'on continue à
monter. Alors par ailleurs, c'est vrai
qu'il y a un développement très rapide
dans le monde de d'énergie comme le
solaire et l'éolien. C'est incontestable
sur le plan industriel. ces énergies
attirent quand même de nombreux
financements. Donc, il y a des choses
qui se passent. Mais euh la le
développement de ces énergies
renouvelable pour pour aller vite,
nouvelles énergies renouvelables, disons
ça comme ça, euh ne prend pas des parts
de marché aux énergies fossiles jusqu'à
aujourd'hui parce que la consommation
mondiale d'énergie continue à augmenter
évidemment des raisons
démographiques, développement des
économiques des pays en développement,
des pays émergents, urbanisation
croissant. Donc il y a plein de raisons
de fond que tout le monde connaît mais
qui sont importantes à rappeler. On
n'est pas dans un monde où la population
est stable et où l'économie mondiale est
stable. On est sur un peu plus de 8
milliards d'habitants 2050 9,5 à 10
milliards. Peut-être un doublement du
produit intérieur brut mondial entre
maintenant et 2050. Ce sont des
projections qui valent ce qu'elles
valent mais voilà. Euh donc qui dit un
doublement de la production énergétique
euh si on alors on peut évidemment
utiliser l'énergie de façon plus
efficace, donc ça veut pas forcément
dire un doublement, mais ça veut pas
dire qu'on va consumer moins d'énergie
en 2050 que maintenant. Ça c'est
absolument impossible. Si c'était le
cas, ce serait un drame majeur sur le
plan économique, social et politique au
niveau mondial. Et puis les pays en
développement et et notamment pensons au
pays africains, il faut espérer qu'ils
vont consommer beaucoup plus d'énergie
dans les années qui viennent.
S'ils ne le font pas, c'est une tragédie
pour eux et pour leur population parce
que le développement c'est lié aussi
quand même à une satisfaction des
besoins en énergie pour faire tourner la
machine industrielle et économique.
Philippe, oui, pour rebondir sur ce que
dit et donner un peu quelques chiffres
en perspective, quand on porte l'indice
de développement humain en fonction de
la consommation d'énergie, on voit qu'on
est un seuil un chiffre assez magique de
30 MWh par an et par habitant. Donc
c'est-à-dire que pour atteindre un
niveau de développement correct, il faut
au moins consommer 30 MWh par an et par
habitant. Combien de zéro à MA ? Comment
? Combien de zéro à MGA ? Méga, il y a
60. Oui, 1 million par rapport au par
rapport au wats. Par rapport au water.
Oui. Et le kilo 1000, on peut aller hein
si on peut tous les faire si vous
voulez. Et donc ce que je disais 30 MWh
chiffre clé dans les pays de l'OCDE, on
est à 45 MWh à peu près en moyenne par
an et par habitant. et on peut encore
optimiser un petit peu, on peut pas
descendre en dessous des 30 sous peines
de plonger assez rapidement dans le
sous-développement. Les pays en voie de
développement aujourd'hui, ils sont à
peu près à 17 et ils vont continuer
d'augmenter pendant que nous on va
continuer à baisser un peu. Sauf que
comme l'a dit Francis, il y a à peu
près, il y aura à peu près en 2050,
c'est 1 pour 9, c'est-à-dire une
personne qui issue des pays de l'OCDE
pour 9 personnes des pays en voie de
développement. Donc quand on quand on
calcule tout ça et qu'on multiplie par 9
et par 1, on va à peu près augmenter de
50 % la consommation d'énergie entre
aujourd'hui et 2050. Il a combien de
mégawurs dans un baril de pétrole ? Dans
un baril de pétrole, il y a 11 11,3
avec une efficacité à 40 %. Non non
point de
vue
transformation transformation thermique
pure combien ? 11,3 11,3 baril non 11,3
MW Ah non c'est 11,3 MWh dans une tonne
équivalent pétrole, pardon. Donc dans un
baril, il faut diviser par 7,5 à peu
près. Donc ce qui fait 11 11,3 divis par
donc ça fait 1,5 à peu près. Voilà. Tu
as fait polytechnique toi ? Non. Euh en
Belgique. En Belgique oui. Personne
n'est parfait dans les 30. Non, mais la
Belgique c'est très bien d'ailleurs, on
on embrasse tous les Belges et et qui
mais qui malheureusement sortent
bêtement du nucléaire pour des raisons
complètement complètement idéologique.
Ils suivent l'Allemagne et puis là le
gouvernement commence à à faire un un
virement à 180° mais sauf que
malheureusement avec le nucléaire non
comme Macron avec le nucléaire. un peu
comme avec le nucléaire, sauf que eux
ont pratiquement fermé la moitié de leur
de leur réacteur aujourd'hui. Alors que
la France heureusement a quand même
changé d'avis suffisamment tôt pour ne
fermer qu'un réacteur. De réacteurs. Le
contenu le contenu énergétique d'un
baril de pétrole brut 1,7 MWh. Bon c'est
pas mal. J'ai dit 1,5
de tête. Oui parce que
ça va. Alors là, on rigole parce que là,
on se fait aider d'intelligence
artificielle. Donc ça nous permet de
calculer tout un tas de bêtises comme
euh le nombre de barils de pétrole qu'on
pay en intérêt avec notre dette, les
intérêts de la dette française euh en
baril de pétrole. Journalier, c'est très
très intéressant de voir que on paye
beaucoup d'intérêt ou du moins beaucoup
d' Mais les gens les gens qui parlent
d'énergie disent toujours l'énergie
c'est rébarbatif parce que il y a trop
de chiffres. Mais si on parle pas de
chiffre en énergie, on peut dire
n'importe quoi. C'est ça le problème.
Il y a beaucoup de zéro dans les
chiffres. Ah, il y a beaucoup de zéro
dans les chiffres. Alors je j'ouvre le
la question du politique et de la
perception de cette clé de voûte par
rapport à nos sociétés
termoindustrielles. Est-ce que nos
politique quand vous écoutez des
discours par exemple comme François
Berérou sur la souveraineté énergétique
française et européenne quand vous
écoutez les politiciens tout spectre
confondu ça vous fait penser à quoi ?
Vous avez l'impression c'est un sketch
où ils sont bien renseignés où ils
racontent n'importe quoi, où il c'est
des belles paroles, c'est des beaux
sculpteur de fumée, des beaux brasseurs
d'air chaud. Nicolas,
ben j'étais justement en train d'y
réfléchir et non, je pense qu'il y en a
certains, on peut quand même noter une
certaine constance, voir une consistance
dans la médiocrité. Non, non, dans le si
on prend par exemple les communistes,
ils ont jamais bougé. Ils ont toujours
été clairs sur ce qu'il fallait faire
sur le nucléaire. C'est les seuls qui
avaient des propositions pertinentes
pendant la crise sur l'électricité et
pour le coup c'est assez stable d'urs.
Après, c'est vrai que c'est une position
qu'ils ont toujours eu. Les pires, c'est
lesquels ?
Bah pas de dénigrement. Non,
vu hein. Attention. Non non, les
pires les pires c'est les
religieux. Les religieux qui se
reconnaîtront. Non non, honnêtement le
le problème c'est qu'en fait il ils
comprennent pas les enjeux. Ils
comprennent pas l'enjeu et ils
comprennent pas. Pourtant c'est quand
même simple. Euh on est un pays on a
hérité de nos parents et de nos
grands-parents d'un formidable atout qui
est ce parc de réacteurs. Presque une
soixantaine de réacteurs nucléaires
qu'on a construit en 25 ans, 30 ans qui
a fait de nous leader mondial de cette
technologie. On était les meilleurs et
ça nous donnait un coût d'électricité
deux fois plus cher que tous les autres
pays. Deux fois moins cher. Oui. Deux
fois moins cher que tous les autres pays
européens. Heureusement que vous Merci
Francis, tu me rebranches. Euh deux fois
moins cher. Euh et donc c'est ça qui a
fait que les entreprises venaient en
France pour ouvrir des usines et c'était
ça notre avantage
compétitif. Et on l'a perdu. On a perdu
pour deux raisons. La première, c'est
déjà parce qu'on est rentré dans ce
marché européen l'électricité et qu'on a
supprimé les tarifs jaunes, les tarifs
verts, donc les tarifs réglementés pour
nos entreprises parce que l'Allemagne
considérait que c'était de la
concurrence des loyales. Donc elles ont
plus perdu ces tarifs et c'est pour ça
qu'elles ont eu beaucoup de problèmes en
de 2022 à 2025. C'est pour ça qu'on a un
record de défaillance entreprises depuis
depuis 30 ans. Donc on a perdu ça et
puis en plus là on voit que notre parc
nucléaire on ferme des centrales flambu
comme Festonheim. Ça nous prend 15 ans
15 milliards à remplacer neuve
parfaitement. Bah elle a été remplacée
était quasiment neuve à part la cuve.
Toutes les pièces avaient été changées
juste avant. Elle fonctionnait elle
fonctionnait parfaitement. Euh et donc
alors qu'on a vraiment cet atout, on
devrait tout faire pour essayer de le
faire durer, le faire marcher le plus
longtemps possible, le mieux possible
comme les Américains qui font
fonctionner leur central 80 années. Nos
centrales au départ c'est une distance
Westing donc c'est les mêmes centrales.
Il y a pas de raison qu'elle dure pas 80
années et dans ce cas-là c'est ça qui
nous permettrait de retrouver une
électricité bon marché. Donc ça devrait
être vraiment le seul angle. Moi c'est
ce que je dis régulièrement. Je suis
d'ailleurs je suis assez perplexe sur la
construction des 6 EPR parce que rien
que la machine me semble un peu
compliquée, assez mal né et si on se
focaliser juste à bien faire ce qui
existe, je pense qu'on pourrait déjà
faire une très belle partie du chemin et
en plus ça coûterait pas très cher.
Francis, est-ce que tu souhaites est-ce
que vous ou souhaites rebondir sur ce
qu'a dit Nicolas ? Peut-être par rapport
à la à la
question, tu disais est-ce que les
responsab politiques sont bien informés
sur ces questionsl ? Alors c'est déjà
une première question et on peut pas
forcément toujours dire oui sans aucun
problème. Les résultats parlent d'eux
même. Alors c'est un élément. Deuxème
question, est-ce qu'ils veulent regarder
certaines réalités en face ? Ce qui est
différent de l'information. 3è élément,
quelle est leur dose de courage
politique par rapport à l'opinion, par
rapport à certains secteurs de
l'opinion, par rapport à certains lobby
et cetera. Donc ces trois questions sont
complémentaires. L'information en est
une mais ce n'est pas la seule. Oui, moi
je rebondirai sur le côté courage.
C'est-à-dire qu'on a mis aujourd'hui
dans la tête des politiques la notion de
climatocatastrophisme. Donc c'est-à-dire
que globalement si on ne décarbone pas à
une vitesse stratosphérique en Europe,
la race humaine va s'effondrer dans les
dans les 10 dans les 10 ans qui
viennent. C'est c'est à peu près ça qui
est qui est véhiculé qui est véhiculé
aujourd'hui. Je grossis un petit peu
mais c'est c'est Ouais. Enfin, il y en a
il y en a qui le qui le véhiculent
vraiment de de cette façon. Il faut voir
comment ça se passe sur les réseaux
sociaux. Et donc, c'est pour ça qu'on
est arrivé à une espèce de religion
carbocentrée. Donc c'est-à-dire qui dit
si on décarbone pas à une vitesse
stratosphérique sans prendre en compte
les conséquences économiques d'un côté,
les conséquences sociétales de l'autre.
Parce que quand on voit on je crois que
Alexandre Jardin est venu assez
récemment pour parler des des ét feu euh
c'est chaîne absolument non c'est parce
que j'ai regardé le qui est son
intervention qui était d'ailleurs tout à
fait intéressante et donc effectivement
ce sont des des espèces de ce que
j'appelle des agendas inversés
c'est-à-dire qu'on se donne en fait des
objectifs tout à fait irréalisa et on
essaie de penser après comment à peu
près pouvoir pouvoir y arriver. Donc le
Green Deal, européen ou les ou l'accord
de Paris, c'est exactement ça. On s'est
dit en c'était en 2016 lors de non,
c'est 2015 des accords de Paris,
décembre 2015. Euh allez, il faut
limiter à 1,5° à l'horizon 2100. Alors,
comment ça personne ne savait à
l'époque. Euh et puis on s'aperçoit que
les 1,5°, on y est déjà à peu près, donc
avec 75 ans d'avance, mais on continue à
enfoncer le clou en disant il faut
maintenir 1,5°. Donc, c'est-à-dire,
alors c'est assez classique hein, chez
les politiques, ça n'est pas uniquement
le fait de l'énergie et du et du climat.
Euh on se lance des objectifs, bah c'est
si on se rappelle, c'était Hollande qui
avait dit "Je vais réduire le chômage
avant la fin de mon mandat sans prendre
aucune mesure pour le faire." La
question est toujours savoir comment on
y arrive. Emmanuel Macron a dit qu'il
baisserait euh les dépenses de 60
milliards, il a raé. Voilà. Donc voilà.
Donc, ce sont des ce que j'appelle des
agendas inversés, c'est-à-dire le
contraire de ce que fait un industriel
et un ingénieur à peu près normalement
constitué. C'est-à-dire
qu'effectivement, il peut se donner un
objectif, mais avant de prononcer
l'objectif, il vérifie d'abord quels
sont les moyens techniques, économiques
et sociétaux pour pouvoir pour pouvoir y
arriver. Et on voit que le Green Deal
aujourd'hui est typiquement un objectif
qui ne sera pas réalisé mais qui par
contre va avoir des conséquences
absolument dramatique en terme
économique et sociétal. Nico, oui, sur
les hommes politiques, je pense qu'il y
a il y a effectivement j'en ai croisé,
il y en a qui comprennent Ah oui,
lesquels ? Il y en a qui comprennent le
sujet euh mais et après il y a deux
autres choses, c'est que c'est pas le
seul sujet. Donc il y a une concurrence
avec d'autres sujets. C'est pas
forcément celui qui est en haut de la
liste. Non mais les bouchons de
bouteilles en plastique ça c'est ça on
parle d'autre chose. il y a une
concurrence entre les sujets et après le
politique qui comprend le sujet, il faut
aussi qu'il ait une fenêtre euh et donc
parfois en fonction du rôle qu'ils ont,
ils ont plus ou moins des fenêtres
médiatiques et s'ils ont pas accès au
médias, s'ils sont pas entre guillemets
ministres ou bah ils ont pas de et donc
souvent ils font leurs arbitrages euh
entre les différents sujets et sauf que
c'est vrai que l'énergie gagne peu
d'arbitrage finalement.
un exemple typique aujourd'hui la la
fameuse PPE hein le la planification
pluriannuelle pour
l'énergie dont la disons la la version
finale a été fortement critiquée par
l'Académie des Sciences et avec des
arguments qui étaient tout à fait
l'académie des sciences la nouvelle
téléréalité c'est quoi l'acadé tu tu
connais pas l'académie des sciences si
on avait Jacques Blamont qui était à
l'académie des sciences on connait très
bien l'académie des sciences Et donc
l'Académie des Sciences a fait cette
remarque. Les politiques se sont aperçus
que dans la PPE il y avait un tas de
conneries mais par contre à partir du
moment où c'est écrit et qu'ils ont
déclaré comme ils ne se trompent jamais,
ils peuvent pas revenir en arrière. Donc
c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont complètement
piégés, je vais dire face à leur propre
image et face à leur propre carrière.
C'est de la cavalerie de sculptage de
fumée. C'est ça à peu près. Oui. On va
faire une expérience de pensée tous les
quatre. Imaginez-vous, nous sommes en
conseil de
défense, en urgence
énergétique. Je suis le président de la
République. Je vous ai convoqué parce
que je suis très inquiet et je vous pose
la question. Les Chinois produisent le
double de l'Europe ont des capacités de
produire le double de l'Europe en terme
énergétique. Les États-Unis pratiquement
trois fois plus.
L'Europe est dans la mouise. Si on ne
rattrape pas les choses, quels quelles
sont les conséquences pour la
diplomatie, la démocratie, nos
industries, le social, le prix de
l'énergie, le prix de l'alimentation et
j'en passerai des meilleurs. Qui veut
commencer ? Francis, mon conseiller
favori. Alors là, il faut un conseil
force de plusieurs heures là pour ces
questions importantes, mais euh c'est
secret défense he ça restera. On l'a on
l'a évoqué tout à l'heure dans nos dans
nos
interventions. L'Europe a un grand
problème par rapport au coût de
l'énergie, par rapport à la Chine, par
rapport aux
États-Unis. Et un coup de l'énergie
élevée, je crois que c'est Nicolas qui
en parlait, mais également toi tu en as
parlé. Euh un coût de l'énergie élevé
euh ça pose des petits problèmes au
consommateurs, c'est-à-dire à tout le
monde, ça pose un petit problème à nos
industriels et donc des conséquences
évidemment suite économique, social et
éventuellement politique. Euh donc ça
c'est euh on a besoin d'une énergie
abondante et relativement bon marché.
C'est quoi relativement bon marché ?
C'est 100 100 € le mW.
C'est alors si on parle ici
de la relance du programme nucléaire
français avec les nouveaux EPR
qu'évoquait tout à l'heure Nicolas hein
100 € c'est c'est beaucoup c'est
beaucoup effectivement si on serait sur
70 que nous annonce François Berou mon
premier ministre non on aura pas pris
pour François Berou comme premier
ministre c'est c'est beaucoup et
d'ailleurs ça inquiète et c'est logique
les industriel notamment ceux qui sont
de gros au consommateur d'énergie, la
chimie, l'acier, tout ça qui vont
déménager ailleurs. C'est ça. Chimie,
acier, vert, saudin, chaud, automobile,
automobile un peu moins énergétique
quand même. Quand même
donc euh deuxème conseiller de défense,
ben moi je rebondirai sur ce que vient
de dire Francis. Donc c'estàdire que je
vous expliquerai monsieur le président
que de vous rappeler euh que les prix du
gaz sont quand même quatre fois plus
élevé en Europe qu'aux États-Unis et
qu'en Chine. Et comme le prix de
l'électricité c'est la dernière source
et c'est le gaz, ça veut dire que ça a
un impact sur les prix de l'électricité.
Donc ça veut dire que globalement
essayer de signer des contrats long
terme sur le gaz pour essayer de faire
baisser le prix du gaz et surtout
d'avoir une stabilité fait que on aurait
stabilité prix du gaz, stabilité prix de
l'électricité, ça serait déjà ça serait
déjà un énorme un énorme progrès.
Francis, avant de repasser la la parole
peutêre effectivement juste pour
rebondir sur ce que viens ce que tu
viens de dire euh le nous avons revenons
aux États-Unis, n'hésitez pas à me
parler franchement première puissance
mondiale monsieur le président euh sous
le président actuel Donald Trump numéro
2 et sous Joe
Biden, la politique était de dire au
milieu industriel européen et asiatique,
"Venez investir chez nous, vous aurez
une énergie
abondante et bon marché, ce qui est
parfaitement vrai. hein. Euh ça avait
commencé sous Joe Biden avec la fameuse
loi IRA Inflation Reduction Act euh où
on parle un peu d'inflation mais on
parle de médicament d'énergie. Enfin
c'est un fourtout mais en tout cas il y
a des dispositions il y avait des
dispositions très incitatives sur
l'énergie. Donald Trump l'IRA veut
mettre ça à la poubelle, c'est pas sa
tasse de thé, mais il comme le disait
Philippe, il capitalise sur les
avantages énormes, les atouts énormes
des États-Unis en tant que très gros
producteur d'énergie fossile avec donc
des prix tout à fait intéressants pour
dire et en plus sa politique de droit de
douane légèrement agressif pour dire
mais vous avez une solution très simple,
vous venez investir chez moi, vous aurez
l'énergie qu'il vous faut à des coûts
très intéressants et vous n'aurez pas
les droits de douanes que que je suis en
train de mettre autour du territoire
américain. Et moi, qu'est-ce qu'il faut
que je fasse ? Président de la France,
6e puissance économique mondiale dans
mes rêves. Il faut que je fasse quoi ?
La même chose, conseiller.
Nicolas parlait tout à l'heure du
nucléaire. Ce n'est pas la réponse parce
que à une question aussi complexe, il
n'y a pas une réponse. C'est un élément
de la réponse. C'est un des atouts de la
France depuis des dizaines d'années
comme tu l'as rappelé Nicolas.
Déjà peut-être commençons, monsieur le
président, par ne pas gâcher les atouts
que nous
avons. Nicolas
effectivement pas gâcher les at que nous
avons mais je crois ou que nous avions
dans certains cas monsieur le président
vous avez une certaine fascination pour
les États-Unis tout. Je vous invite à
vous en inspirer et notamment depuis
depuis depuis Trump parce qu' bout le
Boutan et la Colombie, ils ont choisi un
certain nombre de secteurs industriels
sur lesquels ils voulaient se
réindustrialiser qui sont les
semi-conducteurs, les panneaux solaires
qui sont l'industrie automobile et les
batteries. Je pense qu'on doit faire la
le même travail. D'ailleurs, je l'avais
proposé quand j'étais à France Stratégie
où on doit choisir les secteurs
industriels. On n'est pas obligé de
relocaliser la fabrication de ça dans
notre chaussette, mais fabriquer les
secteurs industriels où on veut
fabriquer chez nous, on veut avoir un
certain degré, une certaine
souveraineté. Et quelque part euh moi je
l'avais écrit dans une note qui a jamais
été publiée. Euh on ce qu'ils ont mis en
place euh le Inflation Reduction Act,
c'est des choses desquelles on doit
s'inspirer. Il ils mettent en place des
des aides à l'achat par exemple sur les
voitures quand elles sont fabriquées
assemblées aux
États-Unis. Euh ils mettent aussi des
critères de localisation. Donc ils vont
donner ses aides à l'achat si la
batterie a été assemblée aux États-Unis.
si des composants, les métaux qui
rentrent dans la batterie ont été
extraits des États-Unis. Donc, il faut
qu'on s'inspire et c'est un peu ce qui
se passe en ce moment. Vous avez un
certain nombre de fournisseurs
d'équipement automobile qui demandent
des critères de localisation dans les
dans les appels d'offre pour qu'on
essaie de fabriquer au maximum en
Europe. Et donc il faut un programme
pour attirer les industriels. Un ordre
de grandeur infation reduction
actiards. Au départ c'était 400
milliards de dollars mais 1000 milliards
de dollars de crédit d'impôts. Crédit
d'impôt c'est automatique. En Europe, on
est à 20 milliards de dollars avec des
formulaires SAFA. Donc il y a quand même
un de un rapport de 1 à 50. Et après,
monsieur le président, avec un prix de
gaz trois quatre fois plus cher, vous
ferez venir personne. Donc il va falloir
que vous repartiez voir votre ami
Vladimir Poutine. Vous êtes pas obligé
d'être devenir meilleur copain mais
essayons de récupérer d'une manière
d'une autre du gaz meilleur marché que
ce qu'on a actuellement parce que sinon
je crains queon aura beaucoup du mal à
faire venir des entreprises. Conseiller
F, c'est ce que j'allais dire aussi.
donc renormaliser nos relations avec la
Russie pour réapporter du gaz de Russie
qui était quand même deux fois moins
cher que le GNL américain qu'on est en
train de d'importer aujourd'hui. C'est
cautionner l'invasion d'intérêt. C'est
vrai. C'est vrai. Mais enfin, si on
arrive à une fin de conflit et qu'on
arrive à à régler tout ça, les Allemands
d'ailleurs, je ne vous cache pas,
attendent avec grande impatience la fin
du conflit pour pouvoir réimporter du
gaz parce que il y a pas que l'industrie
française qui a le couteau sous la
gorge. L'industrie allemande, c'est
encore pire. La deuxième chose que je
pourrais dire, c'est l'automobile. Nous
avions le seul domaine dans lequel nous
avions encore un avantage compétitif par
rapport aux Américains, par rapport aux
Chinois, c'est la voiture thermique. Je
dis toujours que si la Formule 1 était
aux Jeux Olympiques, l'Europe raflerait
toutes les médailles et la Chine ne
ferait que de la figuration. La Chine
l'Europe était au NASCAR, si l'Europe
était faisait du NASCAR, du NASCAR.
Euh, je sais pas, c'est du sport
automobile américain où il tourne. Ah !
Alors là, je sais pas, j'ai pris
l'exemple de la Formule 1, pourquoi pas
? Tout ça pour dire simplement, c'est
que l'Europe a toujours un avantage
considérable sur la voiture thermique
parce que les Européens savent fabriquer
et ont toute la technologie pour
fabriquer des voitures thermiques. Ce
que les Chinois n'ont pas, ils l'ont
bien compris il y a une quinzaine
d'années. Ils ont compris que l'Europe
allait abandonner le thermique et allait
aller vers l'électrique. Aujourd'hui,
ils sont en matière électrique les
Chinois qui ont 15 ans d'avance. Alors
qu'on aurait pu réduire pratiquement de
moitié hein, une voiture thermique
aujourd'hui ça consomme. Euh Nicolas me
corrigera puisqu'il est plus spécialiste
que moi, mais je dirais du 6 L au 100 et
on aurait les capacités technologiques
notamment avec l'IA pour réduire à 3 L
au 100, c'est-à-dire réduire de moitié
notre consommation de pétrole parce que
le pétrole c'est quand même
essentiellement essentiellement les
transports. Faut quand même rappeler que
92 % de l'énergie consommée dans les
transports et du et du pétrole. Donc ça
veut dire que globalement, monsieur le
président, avoir accepté l'arrêt de la
construction des voitures thermiques à
l'horizon 2035, c'est non seulement
suicider l'industrie automobile
européenne
euh dans un premier temps, mais c'est
aussi apporter massivement et donner une
autoroute d'importation au au Chinois.
Euh et tout ça, toujours pour la raison
que j'ai déjà évoqué, c'est-à-dire une
espèce d'urgence climatique que seul les
Européens malheureusement ressentent et
et appliquent. Les Américains
l'appliquaient un petit peu avec Biden,
mais avec Trump c'est complètement
oublié.
Personnellement, monsieur le président,
à la différence de vous deux autres
conseillers, je ne recommanderais pas
que l'Europe recommence à acheter du gaz
russe pour des raisons géopolitiques.
Mais je reviens sur un point qu'évoquait
Nicolas tout à l'heure en parlant de
l'IRA. Alors, quel gaz bon marché vous
suggérer Francis ? Je pense que alors il
y a évidemment l'économie quand on parle
d'énergie puis il y a aussi la
géopolitique
repartir vers une dépendance à l'égard
du gar russe avec le régime de monsieur
Vladimir Poutine au Kremelin. Ça pour
moi, je comprends bien qu'il y a un coût
économique et je que j'assume tout à
fait. Absolument. Je pense que l'Europe
a fait suffisamment pendant longtemps,
notamment nos amis allemands, beaucoup
plus que nous, c'est vrai, mais quand
même globalement, on avait quand même en
2021 la Russie qui présentait 40 % 45 %
de des importations de gaz au niveau de
l'Union européenne, ce qui est quand
même considérable. Donc ça c'était je
pense une grave erreur géopolitique même
si elle se justifiait bien sûr
économiquement. Je reviens sur un point
qu'évoquait Nicolas meant sur l'Iran.
Euh donc sous Joe Biden, le Congrès
américain adopte euh la loi donc
Inflation Reduction Act avec donc des
centaines de milliards de dollars au
début effectivement un peu plus de 360
et puis après ça a encore été revu à la
hausse d'incitation euh accordée par
l'État fédéral notamment les crédits
d'impôts qui évoquaient Nicolas. L'Union
européenne dit "Nous allons riposter."
Donc on met en place un système en
disant voilà aux industries européens,
on a fait ce qu'il fallait, on a fait
notre devoir. Premièrement, il y a un
effet de de chiffre. Deuxièmement, il y
a un effet de simplicité contre
complexité. On met en place une usine à
gaz et les industriels, le dire la
complexité en Europe, ils en ont déjà
suffisamment. Ils disent "Mais regardez
le système américain crédit d'impôt
remarquablement simple avec vous.
falloir remplir plein de formulaires, va
falloir si et cetera, ça marchera pas
votre truc. Les États-Unis resteront
plus incitatifs que vous. Et donc, on va
regarder dans certains industriels, on
va regarder un petit peu vers le grand
large, vers la de l'autre côté de
l'Atlantique. Donc, qu'est-ce qu'on met
comme moyen et les processus qu'on met
en place pour que ce soit le plus simple
possible ? Mais comme on dit dans notre
pays souvent, pourquoi faire simple
quand on peut faire compliqué ? Je mets
j'ouvre une parenthèse et tout le monde
peut répondre.
Ça fait beaucoup de milliard côté
américain de promesses de de subvention
si j'ai bien compris. C'est pas des
promesses, c'est des crédits d'impôts.
Vous faites votre usine. Grosso modo,
c'est le la moitié du coût d'une
batterie. Je crois que c'est 50 dollars
du kilwh. Donc c'est très c'est très
important. On vous paye la moitié de
votre usine, la moitié de votre
production. Mais mais on la paye avec
quoi ? Crédit d'impôt, c'est ça que vous
payez pas impôt impôt magique ? Non,
c'est des impôts que vous payez pas.
C'est le trésor américain qui va perdre
de l'argent qui s'endette de combos
gagner l'argent. Qui va moins gagner de
l'argent ? Qui va moins gagner l'argent
? C'est un crédit d'impôt d'argent.
C'est un crédit d'impôt. La question en
fait est à de à trois bandes. Je vois
beaucoup d'États faire des crédits
d'impôts, des subventions.
Tous ces États emprintent sur les
marchés financiers des milliers de
milliards chaque année. Mais en réalité
énergétique, c'est adossé sur quoi ? Sur
une armée, sur des belles paroles, sur
des beaux projets, sur la belle gulg de
notre président favori. C'est c'est ça
va durer jusqu'à quand tout ça ? le
financement de l'énergie par de l'argent
magique. Alors, il y a pas que de il y a
pas que de l'argent magique, hein. Le
euh l'argent global consacré à
l'énergie, selon l'Agence internationale
de l'énergie, on est à peu près à 2700
milliards de dollars par an. Et
aujourd'hui, on va dire qu'il y a à peu
près encore 50 % fossiles et 50 % qui
vont sur les sur les énergies
renouvelables. Euh alors là-dedans, il y
a énormément de privés quand même hein.
Donc il y a pas que du il y a pas que du
public. Ça c'est des investissements. Ça
ce sont des ce sont des investissements.
Oui. Euh alors je ne sais pas si donc ça
c'est énergie. Donc, c'est-à-dire quand
on parle euh batterie, pilat
combustible, voiture et cetera, ça c'est
pas c'est pas c'est pas complètement
inclus là-dedans. Euh en France, le
dernier rapport qui est sorti du
ministère de de l'économie, euh donc
aujourd'hui, on dépense à peu près 110
milliards d'euros par an dans la
transition énergétique, mais pas
seulement. Des des subventions, c'est à
peu près c'est à peu près entre 20 et
30. Euh donc ça veut dire on a à peu
près 1/3 et donc dans les dans les 120
on inclut si quelqu'un achète une pompe
à chaleur pour la transition
énergétique, une voiture électrique et
cetera. Et pour arriver au Green Deal,
il faut 200 milliards. Pour satisfaire
le Green Deal, il faut 200 milliards
d'euros par an. Donc ce qui va
représenter quand même 6,5 % de PIB
français, ce qui est absolument
absolument énorme et inatteignable. Euh
et donc là-dedans, on va redoubler. Donc
ça veut dire que globalement, on va
arriver à peu près à 60 70
milliards de de dépenses publiques dans
la transition énergétique dans la
transition énergétique en France. Et
évidemment, bah qu'est-ce que vous
voulez cet argent ? Non, il tombe pas du
ciel. Ce sera évidemment de l'argent qui
sera emprunté
pour un pays qui notre pays qui est déjà
légèrement qui est déjà légèrement
endetté qui est en déficit budgétaire
depuis 50 ans. Euh quand l'économie va
bien, on est en déficit. Quand elle va
mal, on est encore plus en déficit. Mais
ça dure quand même année 73 74. Enf ça
commence fin 73. Ça fait combien
d'années ? 40 ans. Euh non, qu'est-ce
que je dis ? 50 ans 50 ans donc ça fait
50 ans depuis le premier choc pétrolier
qu'on a pu un budget à l'équilibre. Oui,
tout à fait. Absolument. Est-ce qu'il y
a une corrélation ? Évidemment la la
corrélation économique c'est
l'accroissement de la dette publique
évidemment. Donc 3300 milliards de de
dollars euh de d'euros pardon mais ça
c'est pas très différent mais parlons en
euros. Euh et donc euh les un état comme
le nôtre qui est très endetté et qui vit
au-dessus de ses moyens de façon
général, là nous ne parlons pas de
seulement de l'énergie, a évidemment un
petit peu de mal quand il faut mobiliser
des ressources très importantes pour les
affecter à des secteurs stratégiques
comme l'énergie. Bien sûr.
Ça va terminer comment cette histoire
Nicolas pour l'industrie européenne,
l'économie européenne, la soutenabilité
de l'euro ? Parce que à force d'avoir
des belles paroles des ministres qui
nous promessent qui nous promettent
100000 personnes travaillant dans le
nucléaire pour 2030 et que ce sera on se
baénira tous dans la scène, on
vivra une époque de coca et de on fera
bombance encore. Ça s'annonce comment
pour notre économie là sans énergie ?
une transition énergétique sans énergie,
sans argent, tout le monde en short à la
plage et pas de crème solaire. Moi, j'ai
une question que je me pose depuis
longtemps, c'est quand est-ce que qui va
siffler la la fin la fin de la
récréation ? Et donc un des candidats
potentiels, c'était les agences de
notation mais j'ai découvert que
récemment il ne n'osait plus
noter la France. Donc la dette de la
France, je sais pas qui récemment. Alors
c'est il y en a trois, il y a Fitch,
Moods et Son Mis. Ouais. Pas MS pardon.
et et il y en a une des trois qui devait
noter la France et finalement elle a
elle a fait l'impasse, elle s'est pas
prononcée parce que elles ont un tout
petit peu peur quand même de faire
tomber le premier domino. Euh et euh je
l'écouté d'ailleurs récemment sur
Syerview David Bavrez hein qui parlait
aussi de que ça allait peut-être devenir
plus compliqué pour nous de lever de la
dette. à partir du moment, on aurait la
concurrence des Allemands qui vont
commencer à à lever 1000 milliards. Donc
ça veut dire que on l'a d'ailleurs vu
dès l'annonce des Allemands, les taux
d'intérêt à la dette 10 ans ont pris euh
ont pris plusieurs on a pris euh 30
points de bas, je crois quasiment.
Donc c'est pour ça qu'on a avec
Philippe, on a d'ailleurs réfléchi à une
petite solution que j'appelle la
quadrature du cercle, c'est-à-dire
comment est-ce qu'on peut en même temps
réduire notre déficit public, réduire
notre déficit commercial, réduire le
déficit carbone pour ceux qui intéresse
et éviter de boire la tasse et et
réduire le déficit de compétitivité de
nos entreprises. Donc on a on
travaillait ensemble dans un groupe de
travail où j'avais le privilège de
représenter la France et Philippe la
Belgique auprès des ingénieurs européens
Engé Europe et on nous a demandé de
réfléchir au financement de la
transition énergétique. Comment est-ce
que c'est un peu le c'est c'est ce
pourquoi on se réunit depuis 30 ans
pendant les COP. C'est comment en gros
les pays riches vont financer les pays
pauvres. Sachant que les pays riches et
les pays pauvres, ils sont plus
exactement les mêmes aujourd'hui qu'il y
a 30 ans. C'est-à-dire que quand par
exemple, on doit faire des des
transferts de technologie vers les pays
émergents, on se rend compte que c'est
les pays émergents qui ont les
technologies comme la Chine par exemple
et que la Chine dit "Je suis toujours un
pays en développement." "Je suis
toujours un pays en développement donc
financez-moi." Donc on a réfléchi à ça
et on s'est dit en fait on a imaginé ce
qu'a fait Donald Trump avec un an et
demi d'avance sauf qu'on n pas fait le
même calcul que lui. Et pourquoi lui
d'ailleurs il le fait Donald Trump ?
parce qu'il sait que sa dette, elle est
pas tenable et qu'il a aussi besoin de
remettre son budget à l'équilibre. Donc
il va devoir et au lieu d'aller taxer
euh les Américains ou les entreprises
américaines, il va plutôt essayer de se
financer un peu sur les importations. Et
donc nous, c'est ce qu'on s'est dit avec
Philippe. Est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
imaginer un système où on pourrait aller
faire parce qu'on doit trouver 50
milliards d'euros si j'ai bien compris
pour boucler le budget ? 40 40
milliards. Bon, ça a le temps de
changer, d'augmenter d'ici là, mais les
vrais chiffres, les Français, les
impôts, ils en ont déjà pas mal. Les
entreprises, si on veut les inciter à
venir, voir qu'elle reste et qu'elle
s'en aille pas, je sais pas s'il faut
rallaudir le fardeau. Et donc, il y a
une formule magique qui permet de
récupérer 40 milliards d'euros sans
taxer les producteurs français, les
exportateurs et sans impacter les
Français. C'estàd qu'on on a imaginé une
sorte de de TVA magique, 8 points de TVA
euh 8 points de TVA sans impact pour le
consommateur. Comment est-ce qu'on fait
? Ben, on va aller euh on va aller sur
le prix à l'importation. Donc je
rappelle hein, la France est 100
milliards d'euros de déficit commercial
hein par an. On va aller 360 cette
année. Non, ça c'était il y a 2020 2022
2022 2024, on est un petit peu moins de
100, je crois. Euh et donc on va aller
euh alors nous on s'est dit moi c'est
une contrainte que j'avais quand j'étais
à France Stratégie, c'est que je dois
faire des choses qui sont compatible
avec les règles du monde. Et les règles
du monde c'est par exemple les règles de
l'OMC. Les règles de l'OMC, qu'est-ce
qu'elles disent ? Elles disent que on
peut pas mettre de taxe à l'importation,
sauf dans deux cas. Si ça touche les
droits humains et si ça touche
l'environnement. Donc moi, j'ai
réfléchi, on doit réfléchir à un critère
sur l'environnement et comme le
principal pays qui est responsable des
déséquilibres mondiaux, c'est la Chine,
on s'est dit qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait
faire qui impacterait la Chine et
accessoirement qui pourrait faire
baisser des émissions de CO2. Et donc
c'est là qu'on on s'intéressait
notamment à la production de charbon et
la part du charbon dans l'électricité.
Et donc on a imaginé un système où on va
imposer par exemple sur la Chine, elle a
61 % de charbon dans son électricité.
Donc on va mettre 61 % de taxe sur les
produits chinois. Qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire concrètement pour le consommateur
français ? Alors moi je vais prendre
l'exemple. Alors nous on a pris
l'exemple d'un t-shirt mais imaginez un
t-shirt qui que vous achetez 2 € en
Chine et qu'il est vendu 10 € en France.
Bah au lieu de l'acheter 2 €
l'importateur va le payer 3 € 10 3,20 €.
Donc l'importateur effectivement au lieu
de faire une marge de x 5 il va faire
une marge de x 4 et
demi. Mais ça va rien changer pour le
client final. Et par contre le
producteur de t-shirt en France, ben ça
va rapprocher, ça va diminuer un peu
l'écart qu'il avait avec lui. Et donc ça
ça permet quand même producteur de
t-shirt en France. Oh, il doit en rester
quelques-uns. Oui. Qui essayent mais
vous savez, je prends juste un exemple,
il y a une belle entreprise le Slip
français c'est un très bel exemple qui
essaie de de produire en
France. Et donc c'est souvent cité comme
un exemple de réussite. Du coton
français, ça c'est plus compliqué. Mais
je crois qu'ils ont essayé de faire du
lin mais le lin c'est un peu moins
agréable. Euh mais ça gratte. Ouais mais
quand on regarde les finances du slip
français, ils ont gagné ils ont c'est
comme une entreprise qui fait 20
millions de chiffres d'affaires qui a
gagné une fois 100000 € net de résultat
depuis qu'il existe. Donc le le
fabriquer en France c'est quand même
très très compliqué.
on n'est pas on n'est vraiment pas aidé
et donc ça permettrait de réduire un
petit peu les écarts et en gros ben
Donald Trump lui il avait fait un calcul
avait dit je vais pris le déficit
commercial divisé par les importations
divisé par de ça c'est ton calcul ben
nous avec Philippe on a pris un autre
calcul qui est par du charbon dans
l'électricité point barre voilà parce
que nous alors c'est qu'en fait l'UMC
tout le monde s'en fout j'ai
l'impression que personne suite aux
annonces de Donald Trump s'est dit qu'il
allait mettre une plante à
l'international
Mais mais donc voilà ce qui est sûr
néanmoins, monsieur le président, c'est
que il y aura pas de
réindustrialisation si on ne fait pas un
rééquilibrage de nos relations avec des
pays comme la Chine. On peut pas être
compétitif avec ces pays-là qui ont un
coût d'énergie et un coût du travail
trois quatre fois plus faible que nous
et qui ont des effets d'échelle surtout.
Les effets d'échelle, c'est très
important dans l'industrie. Aujourd'hui,
ils produisent deux voitures électro
deux voitures sur trois vendues dans le
monde électrique pardon de voitures
électriques sur trois. Donc ils ont des
usines. Nous je vous donne quand on a un
atelier de confection en France où il y
a 30 40 couturières le même en Chine il
y en a 1000. Donc c'est tarif
comment ça des tarifs beaucoup plus
faibles. Ah ben même tarif bien
évidemment. Non non, c'est cinq fois
moins cher la Chine, on divise par 5.
Donc si vous voulez, l'écart est
tellement important, on a été tellement
au niveau européen dans cette
doctrine d'importer de la déflation,
d'exporter de la pollution. Exactement.
On l' fait très bien et sauf
qu'aujourd'hui on est pied point lié et
qu'on est quand même à l'os et qu'on a
besoin de refaire venir nos usines.
Question à mes conseillers favoris. En
terme de représaille de type guerre
économique, est-ce que la Chine va
peut-être se sentir un peu attaquée ?
Est-ce que la Chine va mettre
des des pressions sur ses exportations
de terrar pour que la taxe d'un sur son
t-shirt ne se fasse pas ? On est dans
quel état en terme de robustesse face à
la guerre économique de puissance
prédatrice
agressive et qui sont partis bill en
tête pour nous expliquer que maintenant
la multipolarité des nations, c'est eux
les pilotes. On est dans une actualité
brûlante
avec les mesures annoncées par Trump
hein euh contre à peu près le monde
entier mais visant surtout la Chine
puisqu'on est monté jusqu'à des droits
de douanes de 145
% et que les Chinois sont montés sur les
produits américains jusqu'à 125 %.
Alors, il y a eu ce euh les derniers
jours cette rencontre en Suisse entre
responsable économique américain et
chinois avec un accord qui est le
suivant pour une durée de 90 jours qui
permet de continuer les négociations. On
réduit les droits de douane. Donc les
Américains, ce sera 30 % sur les
importations venant de la Chine et la
Chine, ce sera 10 % sur les importations
venant des États-Unis. C'est pas
définitif. C'est 90 jours, on continue à
négocier. On essaie de trouver un accord
pour sortir par le haut. Chacun de ces
deux pays reconnaissant que des droits
de douanes au-delà de 100 % évidemment
ça veut dire c'est comme l'a dit le le
secrétaire américain au trésor Scott
Bessen, c'est quasiment un
embargo. Euh donc on est en plein
là-dedans. Alors pour revenir sur ce que
disait tout à l'heure
Nicolas sur qui sifflera à la fin de la
récréation et tu ajouter peut-être pas
les agences de notation probablement les
marchés parce que les marchés
eux c'est pas des agences de notation
hein. Ça c'est un point extrêmement
important. Donc représaille. Oui, on est
entré dans une guerre commerciale. Trump
l'a voulu, l'a imposé au monde. Il y a
des réactions. En même temps, lui est
quelque part un petit peu à l'aise en
disant "Mes exportations vers le marché
chinois sont très très inférieures aux
exportations chinoises vers le marché
américain." Donc, je peux me permettre
de partir avec des droits de loin
stratosphériques. J'ai beaucoup plus à
taxer que eux. S'il taxent 100 % des
importations américaines sur leur
marché, c'est beaucoup moins que 100 %
des importations chinoises vers les
États-Unis. Mais la classe pauvre
américaine, elle va pas s'embraser si
elle est obligée de son slip. C'est un
c'est un une vraie question. Euh à quel
moment est-ce que l'électorat de Trump
euh le peuple américain en général,
l'électorat de Trump en particulier euh
se diront bon là ce qui fait quand même
en terme de conséquences économiques euh
inflation, baisse du pouvoir d'achat par
ses droits douanes donc qu'il a imposé
ou qu'il est en train qu'il a déjà
imposé et puis ensuite on négocie. Euh
donc lui, il se dit il y a pas de
problème puisque les gens vont céder
devant moi. Par conséquent, ces droits
de douanes très élevés que j'ai mis vont
pas durer très longtemps puisque je vais
pouvoir les abaisser puisqu'ils vont me
donner ce que je veux. Bon, c'est
peut-être une vision un peu optimiste.
Alors, quand on est le président de la
Première Puissance
mondiale, on peut penser que le monde
entier va fléchir devant vous.
Monaco peut pas le penser, c'est clair.
Est-ce queil n'est quand même pas un peu
trop optimiste, notamment par rapport à
un mastonde comme l'économie chinois ?
Francis, je voudrais que tu reviennes
sur les marchés vont siffler la fin de
partie, ça va se matérialiser comment ?
Au niveau des taux d'intérêt ?
euh moins euh on a confiance dans la
capacité d'un pays à rembourser sa dette
publique ou à lever de l'impôt. Donc
c'est un facteur évidemment de risque.
Et à ce moment-là, bah les taux
d'intérêt euh euh qui sont la
conséquence du du risque, si on estime
que le risque est plus élevé, ça va
monter et ça va alourdir le poids de
remboursement de la dette française
puisque nous parlons de la France,
monsieur le président, qui est déjà
élevé. Euh chaque année, on a une charge
de de remboursement de la dette qui est
élevée mais avec des taux d'intérêt qui
pour l'instant sont relativement bas. Si
ce taux d'intérêt augmente, évidemment
ça augmentera et ça ce sera très lourd
pour nous. Philippe, les spread, on en
parle ou alors moi je dirais que quand
on voit les chiffres et surtout les
volumes que la Chine peut peut produire
en terme de de matière première, ce que
je vais dire c'est qu'on est dans un
match qui est déjà devenu complètement
inégal et sans espoir qui et puis en
plus on l'a pas vu venir et qu'en plus
on n pas vu venir enfin deux chiffres
intéressants. En 2000, la Chine
produisait 5 % de l'acier mondial.
Aujourd'hui, c'est 55 %. Donc, c'est
plus de la moitié de de l'acier mondial.
C'est 60 % de l'aluminium, c'est 90 %
des terres rares. Si pu, il faut quand
même dire que c'est aussi pour ses
propres besoins. Certains pour ses
propres exemple des voitures
électriques, elle fait les deux tiers
mais c'est les de tiers pour elle.
l'envo encoreérieur vrai euh mais disons
qu'en matière d'aluminium par exemple,
elle en exporte elle en exporte elle en
exporte beaucoup. Donc c'est-à-dire
qu'on a beau dire aujourd'hui on va
réouvrir des mines, on va encore une
fois le seul le seul talon d'Achile, on
l'a déjà dit tout à l'heure mais c'est
intéressant de le répéter de la Chine
c'est sa faiblesse en terme
d'hydrocarbure et sans hydrocarbure elle
peut rien faire. Euh la Chine à la
Russie, pardon ? la Chine à la Russie.
Oui et non parce que alors en matière de
pétrole, c'est vrai mais en matière de
gaz, c'est beaucoup moins vrai parce
qu'en fait il y a pas euh de pipe de de
gaz auuc euh aujourd'hui euh
opérationnel ou suffisamment
opérationnel entre euh la Chine et le et
et la et la Russie. Il faut combien de
temps pour faire un pipe ? Il y en a un
sol. Ah, il faut un pipe. Ça peut durer
euh entre le début du projet, ça peut
durer une dizaine d'années, hein. Donc
euh surtout qu'en plus, ce sont des
reliefs comme l'Altaille et cetera qui
sont extrêmement complexes. Donc, c'est
très coûteux et ça peut être et ça peut
être ça peut être très long. Mais
aujourd'hui, quand quand je regarde les
chiffres les uns les uns après les
autres, que ce soit les batteries, les
piles à combustible, les voitures
électriques et cetera, on peut on peut
on peut tous les prendre les uns après
les autres. On voit pas comment on va
pouvoir rattraper ça et on on va devenir
il y a une une certaine vassalisation du
monde face à la Chine et face à sa
puissance économique qui est devenue
absolument euh sidérante en en quelques
années sinon quelques dizaines d'années.
C'est sa puissance économique ou la
faiblesse de nos intellectuels qui a
permis ça ? Ah je crois que je crois
qu'il y a je crois qu'il y a les deux.
On a fait énormément d'erreurs dont ils
ont dont ils ont extrêmement bien
extrêmement bien profité. Cela étant,
comme l'a dit Nicolas, bon ben ils ont
un coût du travail qui reste très faible
par rapport à celui de l'Europe. Ils ont
un coût de l'énergie qui reste très
faible par rapport à celui de l'Europe.
Donc c'est-à-dire que si on voulait
réellement
réindustrialiser comme monsieur le
président, vous ne cessez de de nous de
nous le dire, bah effectivement, il faut
absolument revoir notre modèle social.
Est-ce que les Français sont prêts à
l'entendre ? J'en suis j'en suis
beaucoup moins sûr, mais disons que
globalement rivaliser aujourd'hui avec
les Chinois, avec leur modèle social et
notre modèle social, je crois que c'est
un match entre le PSG actuel et
une, je vais dire une petite équipe de
province. Par rapport à ce que disait
Philippe à l'instant sur le gaz Russie
Chine, il y a au moment où nous parlons
un gazoduc en fonctionnement qui permet
à la Russie d'exporter du gaz gaz prom
vers à la
Chine. Il y a en projet un deuxième
gazoduc et les Russes sont très
demandeurs. Les Chinois
temporisent. Pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
temporisent ? pour au moins deux raisons
dans le désordre peu importe les deux
sont importantes. Première raison, plus
il temporise, plus c'est une pression
sur les Russes pour qu'il baissent le
prix. Deuxième raison, les dirigeants
chinois savent que l'énergie c'est
stratégique, ce qui est évident, mais
parfois tout le monde ne le sait pas. Et
donc quand c'est stratégique, il ne faut
pas être trop dépendant d'un pays
exportateur. Ils ne veulent pas refaire
l'erreur faite par l'Union européenne
par rapport au gaz russe. Et donc
l'Allemagne absolument surtout
l'Allemagne, mais c'était quand même, on
le disait en 2021 à 45 % des
importations gazières de l'Union
européenne avec évidemment un des points
très importants comme l'Allemagne,
première économie de l'Union européenne.
All c'était jusqu'à 60 %. Oui, c'était
plus 40 45 % c'est une moyenne pour en
sachant que la France c'est à peu près
17 % on était beaucoup moins dépendant
du gaz russe parce qu'on apportait
beaucoup de gaz naturelfi. Euh et donc
les dirigeants chinois euh ils mettent
la pression sur les Russes pour dire
vous pourriez pas baisser encore un
petit peu vos prix pour qu'on vous en
achète un peu plus mais il continue à
importer du gaz venant d'autres pays
asiatiques, par exemple Indonésie,
Malaisie. Euh, ils apportent du gaz
naturel liqufié de l'Australie, pays
occidental très proche des États-Unis.
Ils importent du gaz du Moyen-Orient,
notamment Qatar et cetera. Donc, ils
veulent garder les abdos diversifiés.
États-Unis aussi. Alors, même si avec
actuellement le le duel sur le Mais tu
as tout à fait raison, Nicolas aussi,
ils du gén américain. Exactement. Donc
ils ne font pas cette erreur. Vladimir
Poutine a plein de gaz à leur ventre
puisqu'il a il perd le marché européen
qui était son principal marché depuis
des dizaines d'années. Il a pas encore
complètement perdu mais il est largement
perdu et ça va continuer. Donc il y a
trois grands marchés pour le gaz dans le
monde. L'Europe, l'Amérique du Nord,
l'Asie. l'Amérique du Nord, on a des
pays qui sont producteurs. États-Unis,
premier exportateur mondial, premier
producteur et Canada, gros producteur.
Donc, on peut pas aller vendre du gaz
russe en Amérique Nord. Ils en ont pas
besoin, ils ont suffisamment pour eux et
ils exportent massivement le reste du
monde. Donc, il reste l'Asie, donc
notamment la Chine. C'est pas un très
gros marché encore pour le gaz. Et les
Russes ayant les plus grosses réserves
prouvées de gaz dans le monde, étant le
deuxè producteur mondial de gaz jusqu'à
tout récemment avant la guerre en
ukraine, le premier exportateur, ont
besoin de marchés très importants. Donc
il ne reste plus que l'Asie,
principalement Chine, Inde. Et les
Chinois connaissent ce rapport de force,
donc ils jouent là-dessus. Et alors que
monsieur Poutine les gaz voudrait dire
"Allez quand est-ce qu'on lance ce
deuxième gazoduc là pour voilà resserrer
nos liens l'amitié éternelle entre deux
pays face à l'Occident global qui sont
tous des affreux." Les Chinois pendant
ce temps font leur compte et se disent
pas si vite mon ami Vladimir là tu
parles de comme comme gazoduc de
l'Altaille c'est ça c'est l'Altaille qui
a pas été construit c'est le force de
Sibérie qui a bien été force de Sibérie
1 et il doit y avoir qui existe mais
c'est le seul gazonu qui existe et il y
a un deuxième qui serait force de
Sibérie 2 mais pour laquelle les Chinois
traînent les pieds. Oui, c'est ça. Et
donc c'est le force de Sibérie 2, c'est
une entrée ouest alors que l'autre c'est
une entrée est sur c'est sur la Chine.
Je pense que sur ce sujet, pour rebondir
sur ce que disait
Francis, la position de Trump face au
canal de Panama est assez intéressante.
Il faut quand même savoir que le canal
de Panama est essentiellement utilisé
pour véhiculer des méthagniers, donc du
gaz naturel liquéfié et ce
essentiellement vers la Chine. Donc ça
veut dire
que est-ce que Trump a dans l'idée cette
espèce de de plan maiavélique de dire
arrêtons la guerre en Ukraine, les
Européens vont un petit peu se
rabibaocher et
réimporter du gaz russe. C'est tout à
fait possible. Et dans un deuxème temps,
du coup, les Chinois n'en auront pas
assez et donc ils devront importer du
gaz naturel de l'IKFI américain que les
Américains n'exporteront plus vers
l'Europe puisque le gaz russe viendrait
en en comment dirais-je en remplacer une
partie. Je pense qu'il doit avoir ça
derrière la tête avec notamment la main
mise sur le canal de Panama. Je doute
que Donald Trump veuille que son pays
exporte moins de gaz naturelfier vers
l'Europe. Il demande au contraire aux
européens d'importer plus de gaz, donc
en l'occurrence gaz naturel liquifié
puisqu'il y a l'Atlantie contre les deux
et de pétrole des États-Unis pour
réduire l'excédent commercial que
l'Union européenne a dans ces échanges
avec les États-Unis. Donc à mon avis,
c'est c'est le contraire.
J'ai je suis je suis je suis je suis pas
je suis pas certain en apparence en
apparence peut-être. Mais alors pourquoi
quel quel est son intérêt à ce
moment-là, du moins sur le gaz,
d'arrêter le conflit le conflit
russo-rainien ? parce qu'il sait très
bien qu'en arrêtant le conflit
russo-rainien, inévitablement les Russes
vont réexporter du gaz vers l'Europe et
donc réimporter moins de gaz naturel de
gaz naturel américain. On sait que les
Allemands attendent avec impatience la
fin du conflit pour pouvoir réimporter
du gaz russe. He il y a quand même
encore deux gaz auoduc qui sont
opérationnels, hein. Le le Yamal et le
et le vers l'Allemagne. vers
l'Allemagne, il y a le Yamal qui
traverse la Biélorussie et le le le pipe
de la fraternité, le Brotherhood qui
traverse l'Ukraine non choisi un peu à
contesens de l'histoire mais dans les
années dans les années 60 et donc ça
veut dire que globalement je comprends
mal son jeu à ce moment non comment
c'était pas des installements qui
avaient fait le pipe
euh c'était c le le maître
60 68 l'ouverture du premier du premier
gazoduc celui qui traverse l'Ukraine qui
s'appelle le Brotherhood hein qui veut
dire qui a fait péter leur stream pas
probablement l'Ukraine mais on n'a pas
de certitude dans ce genre de chos
évidemment ceux qui font ça ne laissent
pas une lettre de revendication ne
publiqua pas un communiqué de presse à
l'époque et kayak à l'époque on pensait
plus au on pensait plus aux Américains
justement pour éviter Biden
qui avait qui s'était fortement opposé
hein à la construction de du Nordstream
2 si je me souviens bien voulait il
reste un
non les deux les deux sont plus opta qui
s'était opposé et Biden avait levé les
sanctions. Il y a Nordstream 1 et
Nordstream 2. Chacun a deux tuyaux donc
ça fait quatre tuyaux.
fin septembre 2022, lors de cette
attaque, il y a un seul tuyau qui reste
intact sur 4. C'est ça. Et le Nordstream
1, lui date de 2012 si je me souviens
bien. Et le Nordstream le Nordstream 2 a
été commissionné mais n'a jamais été
utilisé. Il a il a été détruit avant que
le premier mètre c de gaz puisse être
véhiculé.
Moi oui, je voulais juste reprendre un
peu de recul par rapport aussi ce qui a
été dit et si on donc on regarde les
quatre les quatre grandes zones
États-Unis, Russie, Chine, Europe. Tu te
demandais pourquoi les les Américains
voulaient la fin de ce conflit en
Ukraine ? Je pense qu'ils sont ils
veulent se refocaliser sur le
l'opposition avec la Chine. Donc ils
veulent décrocher un peu la Russie de la
Chine et accessoirement ils sont aussi
intéressés par toutes les réserves de
métau qu'à la Russie et pas d'ailleurs
pas forcément l'Ukraine puisque c'est
plutôt en Russie que ça se passe. Donc
eux ils ont besoin de s'ils peuvent
s'ils veulent se rabibocher avec les
Russes, ils ont quand même intérêt à ce
que le conflit soit soit terminé. C'est
un peu le préalable à ce truc-là. Nous
en Europe finalement on a qui ? On a les
Américains qui sont face à nous. À mon
avis, ils vont pas nous faire de
cadeaux. Là, on a déjà 25 % de taxe sur
l'acier, sur les voitures européenne. Ça
c'est compliqué. Pas sûr. Sur le
beauelet.
Euh, on est là champagne, on a Bernard
Arnaud est allé négocier là, je sais pas
s'il l'a eu. Et et donc on a donc les
Américains qui quand même se rapprochent
d'une meilleur d'une are des des Russes,
des dirigeants européens et francis qui
ont pas vraiment envie de de travailler
avec la Russie et les Chinois qui
perdent un des principals marchés qu'ils
avaient déjà perdu et donc tout ce
qu'ils peuvent plus vendre aux
États-Unis parce que je rappelle qu'il y
a quand même des taxes à l'importation
de 100 % sur les voitures électriques
euh 100 % sur les panneaux solaires chez
bêtises peut-être 50. Donc tout ça se
déverse sur l'Europe. Donc nous on doit
s'organiser et on doit mettre en place
un partenariat avec les Chinois pour
rééquilibrer cette relation. Et en fait
ça se voit, on le fait déjà en ce moment
entre guillemets parce que quand on
regarde les usines de batterie qu'on a
mis en place en Europe, en fait c'est
beusine de batterie, c'est beaucoup de
robots, c'est beaucoup de machines et
ces machines elles sont pas fabriquées
en France. Elles sont fabriquées soit en
Chine, soit en Corée du Sud, soit au
Japon puisque c'est eux qui maîtrisent
la la technologie. Et aujourd'hui, ben
dans ces usines, on est obligé de faire
venir des Chinois pour qu'il nous
expliquent comment elle marche. Euh et
donc en fait ce que nous on a fait il y
a 30 ans en Chine où on est allé
installer des usines en cours-entreprise
et on a transféré des technologies, et
ben maintenant il faut que ce soit
l'inverse. Donc on va on va devoir de
toute façon on pourra pas se passer des
Chinois. Il faut simplement que les
usines au lieu d'être en Chine, elles
soient chez nous. Et donc c'est aussi la
raison pour laquelle Donald Trump met en
place ses droits de douanes pour
relocaliser des usines. Alors je sais
pas si c'est avec des droits de douanes
qu'on doit discuter avec les Chinois
mais il faut qu'on puisse rééquilibrer
cette relation parce que les Chinois
avec leur made in China 2025, ils se
sont positionnés sur toutes nos
industries en Europe et si on ne fait
rien, ils vont nous laminer. Philippe
disait quelque chose d'intéressant,
c'est-à-dire que notre modèle social, il
est pas du tout aligné sur le modèle
social chinois. C'estàd que euh le SMIC
en Chine, c'est combien ?
Ah, c'est trop moins 350 € je crois.
C'est comme un SMIC ukrainien, c'est
bien, non ? Ça près 350 €. Ouais. Non,
puis surtout il y a quelque chose aussi
sur les Chinois, c'est que si on va au
conflit avec les Chinois, euh la
capacité, eux, ils ont une revanche à
prendre, pas nous. Donc la capacité du
peuple chinois à faire des efforts et se
serrer la ceinture et à encaisser est
bien plus importante que celle du peuple
européen ou du peuple français. Et ça ça
peut faire la différence. Oui, il faut
faut quand même aussi ne pas oublier que
le système politique en Chine est un peu
plus autoritaire que qu'en Europe et que
donc des détails, c'est un détail mais
cela étant que quand monsieur Sjin
Ping les meutes de personnes par
donc c'est un point complémentaire qu'il
ne faut pas oublier. Trump est un homme
d'affaires donc il faut lui parler
dollars. C'est ça qui
l'intéresse. Le président
Zelenski lui a dit après son élection en
novembre, nous avons un potentiel
important de terre rares de différentes
ressources minières pour en espérant
garder l'attention de Trump pour qu'il
continue à aider l'Ukraine. Le président
Poutine lui a dit "Non, on en a encore
plus et c'est vrai qu'ils ont un
potentiel énorme." Euh les dirigeants
iraniens, ce qui paraît plus surprenant,
disent depuis quelques semaines mais aux
investisseurs américains, "Venez,
investissez chez nous." Ils ajoutent
"Vous ne pouvez pas du fait des
sanctions américaines contre l'Iran. Si
on levait ces sanctions, vous auriez des
opportunités économiques en Iran." Je
cite le ministre des affaires étrangères
se chiffrant en milliers de milliards de
dollars. Évidemment, le chiffre est
complètement faux. Il est grossièrement
faux. Mais ils ont compris que Trump
n'est pas un homme de chiffres. Tous les
chiffres qu'il donne sont faux et
grossièrement faux. Donc mais il faut
lui donner plein de dollars pour attirer
son œil, son oreille, son attention. Et
donc chacun essaie de jouer la carte
économique en disant voilà si on se
rapproche, si on développe un
partenariat, d'une part on se tapera pas
dessus, ce qui peut être intéressant et
par ailleurs, il y aura plein
d'occasions intéressantes pour les
entreprises américaines. Quel est l'un
des mantras de Trump de bons contrats
pour l'industrie américaine, de bons
emplois pour les travailleurs américains
? Euh je pense que c'est intéressant de
rebondir sur le le les métaux parce
qu'effectivement euh c'est un point qui
me paraît crucial dans la relation entre
les Américains et les Chinois. Euh donc
comme je l'ai dit, les Chinois ont mis
la main sur Alors, c'est pas seulement
d'ailleurs on parle toujours de métau
rares, mais moi je dirais métau critique
hein parce que parmi ces métaux, le le
premier qui risque de poser un problème
mondial en terme de euh de ressources
insuffisantes, c'est le cuivre qui n'est
pas un métal rare. Alors, il est un peu
plus rare que le fer, mais enfin, il est
il est quand même pas très très rare. Ça
se chiffre en millions de tonnes et pas
en milliers de tonnes par an.
Euh et ce qu'on voit ben c'est que les
Chinois non seulement ils ont dans leur
sous-sol énormément de de potentiel
métallique mais ils ont surtout mis la
main sur les productions d'un certain
nombre de pays voisins. Le meilleur
exemple, c'est voisin ou pas voisin d'
voisins ou pas voisin que l'Afrique
Amérique latine. Tout à fait tout à fait
de pays tiers, je voulais dire pas de
pays voisin de pays tiers mais un
exemple alors absolument typique c'est
l'Indonésie. Donc l'Indonésie est
maintenant le premier producteur de
nickel. Il ne produisait pratiquement
pas de nickel il y a 10 ans. Et en 10
ans, grâce aux investissements massifs
chinois, le l'Indonésie produit
maintenant la moitié du nickel mondial.
Euh la technique chinoise, ça a été
d'envahir les marchés mondiaux de
nickel, ce qui a fait complètement
effondrer les prix. Et puis à partir du
moment où on effondre les prix, bah il y
a un tas d'acteurs parallèles qui
disparaissent. Cétait le cas notamment
pour la France de la Nouvelle-Calédonie
qui est dans dans dans difficultés
absolument absolument énorme. Et donc ce
côté métau critique au sens large, je
crois va être une donnée géopolitique
assez assez importante et même assez
cruciale au cours des au cours des au
cours des prochaines années, notamment
parce que la transition
énergétique va être
demandeuse d'énormément de de métau
critiques. Et d'ailleurs à ces métau
critiques, on peut aussi rajouter
l'uranium qui va être essentiel en terme
de de développement du nouveau
nucléaire. Et là encore une fois la
France s'est coupée l'herbe sous le pied
quand on pense qu'elle a grâce aux
déchets nucléaires et les le nucléaire
de 4e génération c'est-à-dire Super
Phonix et Astrid que les écolons ont
absolument voulu arrêter pour encore une
fois des raisons purement
idéologiques alors que ça donnerait et
ça aurait donné à la France une
souveraineté
énergétique inattendue et tout à fait
tout à fait importante. On estime que
tout ce qui est stocké à la
Hague donnerait à la France en matière
de nucléaire 1000 ans d'autonomie
d'autonomie d'autonomie énergétique au
moins en terme de nucléaire. Ça ne
résout pas tout mais en tout cas c'est
encore un exemple où on a complètement
rassé raté le train. Moi j'avais une
j'avais une question pour le conseiller
Francis. Ah qui Francis qui parlait de
de Trump qui aim bien les dollars. Alors
quel quel dollar les Européens
pourraient-il montrer à Donald Trump
pour l'attirer et le faire
l'is la l'apprivoiser ? Ah, en tout cas
clairement ce qu'il nous demande euh
c'est que nous fassions ce qu'il faut
donc en important plus des États-Unis 35
dollars de gaz naturel liquéfié euh et
pétrole puisque il exporte aussi de plus
en plus de pétrole même s'il n'est pas
le numéro 1 mondial, c'est l'Arabie
Saoudite qui reste le premier
exportateur mondial.
Euh ça peut être l'agriculture également
bien sûr, ce qui peut poser quelques
petits problèmes par rapport à au modèle
européen. Mais en tout cas depuis
novembre à peine élu l'une de ces
premières déclarations, c'est les
Européens, il faudra importer beaucoup
plus de GNL américain et de pétrole
américain parce que votre déficit, votre
excédent commercial par rapport à moi
dans nos échanges, ça va pas durer comme
ça. On l'avait on l'avait déjà fait en
juillet 2018, on avait fait un deal. Pas
de taxe à l'importation sur les voitures
allemandes compte du gaz naturel
liquéfié et du soja OGM. Et
depuis le le déficit augmenté. Donc
Trump s'est déjà fait avoir une fois, il
s'est fait rouler dans la farine une
fois. C'est un peu c'est c'est un peu le
chien qui se mort la queue parce que euh
on a dit que notre déficit commercial
est il est il est un petit peu inférieur
à à 100 milliards d'euros hein Nicolas
on a dit euh euh cette année et sur les
100 milliards d'euros il y en a quand
même c'est 75 ou 80 de pétrole et de
gaz. Donc ça veut dire que globalement
euh combler le ou attirer attirer Trump
ou disons le rendre un peu plus gentil
en apportant davantage de pétrole et de
gaz, c'est pas ça qui va résoudre notre
problème. dépend du prix du gaz parce
que si on laisse la Russie al même si
c'est pas nous qui l'achetons mais si on
enlève les sanctions sur sur le gaz
russe ça peut faire baisser les cours
aussi au niveau le gaz naturel liquéfié
par définition parce que il faut le
liquéfier et puis le transporter donc le
refroidir il faut quand même savoir que
le gaz naturel liquéfié on le refroidit
à - 163°gr donc ça veut dire que ce sont
d'énormes frigos qui coûtent très cher
et qui sont d'ailleurs énergétivor hein
le gaz naturel
liquéfié est consommateur d'énergie
beaucoup plus que le gaz naturel qui
n'est pas liquéfié et qu'on exporte par
gaz auc. Et et donc ça veut dire que
encore
augmenter la quantité de gaz naturel
liquéfié des États-Unis, c'est augmenter
notre dépendance des États-Unis et ne
pas réduire le prix de l'énergie. Donc
je trouve que c'est un peu un marché
dupe. Je voulais revenir sur ce que
disait Philippe qui a raison de parler
de minerais métacritique et pas de se
focaliser uniquement sur ces fameuses
terres rares qui sont pas toujours rares
d'ailleurs mais qui font partie de
l'ensemble. Mais c'est l'ensemble qu'il
faut regarder. Euh par rapport au poids
de la Chine qui est incontestable sur le
marché mondial dans ce
domaine-là. Il y a le poids que tu
évoquais Philippe par rapport à
l'extraction de ces ressources. Oui, il
y a ce qu'on évoquait également par
rapport à ce qu'ils vont faire dans
d'autres pays y compris lointain comme
des pays africains.
Mais il y a aussi le fait qu'il maîtrise
le raffinage le raffinage
de ses ressources et leur part dans le
raffinage mondial de ces ressources est
plus élevé que leur part dans la
production mondiale de ces ressources.
On atteint un chiffre de 90 % dans
certains cas ce qui est absolument.
Est-ce qu'on ne sait pas raffiner des
métaux et des minerais aux États-Unis et
en Europe ? Bien sûr que si, mais on a
sous-traiter ça depuis longtemps disant
finalement c'est sale, c'est pas propre,
ça coûte cher, c'est polluant, les
Chinois vont le faire donc comme ça
c'est eux qui auront la pollution, ils
le feront moins cher et puis après ils
exporteront. Tout ça est intéressant
économiquement sur le plan
environnemental, sur le plan
stratégique, sur le plan de la
souveraineté. C'est absolument
désastreux. Euh l'Union chipote, tu
chipes, je chipote, je chipote, je
chipote. Alors, l'Union européenne veut
être le leader euh de la transition
énergétique. Elle veut beaucoup de
choses aussi. Elle veut beaucoup de
choses. Mais comment est-ce qu'on fait
une transition énergétique sans mine et
sans énergie ? Mission
impossible. Sauf que les mines, c'est
sales, beaucoup plus sale que le
pétrole. Absolument. Tout à fait. Donc
il y a un moment donné, il faudra un peu
de temps en temps être cohérent. Nous
voulons du solaire, de l'éolien et
cetera. Très bien. OK, d'accord, pas de
problème. Nous aurons besoin d'augmenter
de façon très importante la production
d'un certain nombre de minerais et de
métaux critiques. Et il serait quand
même dommage d'apporter tout. Alors,
quand on n pas de potentiel minié dans
notre sous-sol, la question se pose pas.
Mais parfois, on en a et on ne veut pas
l'exploiter. Comment on fait pour
expliquer ça aux écologistes ?
et pour expliquer à l'opinion publique
et au responsable politique. Comment on
fait pour expliquer tout ça ? Ah ben
c'est on y on y arrive pas. La preuve
c'est que Francis comment fait ? Je veux
dire il faut vraiment vous voulez la
transition vous avez besoin de mine à ce
moment-là dites que vous ne voulez pas
la transition. Vous pouvez pas dire je
veux la transition et pas de bide, c'est
pas possible. Pas avoir le beurre,
l'argent du beurre, la crémière, la
vache et la ferme. C'est absolument
c'est une façon clair et nette de Il y a
un exemple typique en France hein, c'est
que
euh donc Eramet veut rouvrir une mine
dans l'allié. Alors, c'est une ancienne
mine de boxite, hein, donc de minera de
d'aluminium. Il y a plus de boxite mais
par contre il y a du lithium parce que
le lithium est toujours associé associé
à à la boxite. Et donc en fait le BRGM a
fait une étude qui montre qu'il serait
tout à fait économique de produire du
lithium dans l'allié. Je vous rappelle
que le lithium est l'ingrédient de base
pour fabriquer les voitures. He c'est
l'électrolyte des voitures des voitures
électriques. C'est pas le traitement
dans l'Assemblée nationale. Non c'est
pas ça. Non non c'est pas ça. Non. Et
donc ce qui s'est passé, c'est
qu'effectivement euh alors les normes
ont évidemment été euh n'ont rien à voir
avec les normes qu'on peut imposer en en
Chine, en Bolivie ou bien ou bien au
Chili. Donc ce sont des normes déjà
environnementales extrêmement strictes
euh qui vont évidemment augmenter le
prix du lithium par rapport au prix.
Mais admettons, bah les écologistes sont
contre parce qu'effectivement il y a une
grosse consommation d'eau parce que
quand on fait de la mine, on consomme
évidemment beaucoup d'eau pour séparer,
on va pas rentrer dans le détail mais
pour séparer le lithium des autres
minerais, il faut il faut laver le
minerais, le broyer et cetera et puis
vous rejetez effectivement le minerai
sans lithium qu'on appelle la gangue. Et
donc tout ça comme l'a dit comme l'a dit
Francis, même si on suit des processus
et des et des procédés environnementaux
extrêmement strict, la mine ça reste
quelque chose de dégueulasse. Après, on
peut la reboucher certes et replanter,
mais enfin tout ça coûte énormément
d'argent qui vont finir par rendre le
projet non économique.
Ouais, peut-être c'est ça peut être le
moment d'aborder un point un peu
saillant au niveau européen. Vous savez,
on dit souvent les États-Unis innovent,
la Chine fabrique et l'Europe
réglemente. Et c'est vrai que en fait en
Europe, on est capable de faire des
choses
incroyable quand on met une exception
sur la réglementation, c'est-à-dire par
exemple reconstruire une cathédrale
comme
Notre-Dame, organiser des Jeux
Olympiques. Donc en fait, on est
étouffé. Bruxelles, c'est une machine à
fabriquer de la norme. Les gens sont
payés à faire ça toute la journée. Ils
fabriquent, ils fabriquent des normes et
donc elle s'empile, elle s'empile, elle
s'empile, elle remplace jamais, elle
s'empile en plus. Euh et aujourd'hui, il
va falloir, si on veut pouvoir avoir un
projet, proposer un projet à nos enfants
en Europe, il va falloir y aller au
scalpel en fait, voir au carcher.
C'est-à-dire que les scalpel ou à la
hache, peut-être que la hache sera
peut-être plus efficace, ça ira plus
rapidement, mais ça me fait un petit peu
peur parce que vous savez cette histoire
de simplification, ça fait 20 ans qu'on
en parle en France, tout le monde nous
explique qu'on va tout simplifier mais
on a du mal à voir des résultats
concrets. Mais c'est qu'en Europe, si je
prends l'exemple, on parlait du
nucléaire tout à l'heure. Pourquoi
est-ce que les Américains euh prolonge
la durée de vie de leur réacteur à 80
années quand nous on est à 50, on aura
du mal à y aller parce qu'en fait ils
ont pas la même réglementation. Les
Américains quand ils doivent prolonger
la durée de vue de leur réacteur
nucléaire, ils doivent respecter le
cahier des charges lors de la
fabrication du réacteur. Donc c'était
bah il y a 40 ans ou 50 ans. Nous, on
doit respecter le cahier des charges euh
de l'EPR.
Donc donc c'est très compliqué. C'est
comme si on avait une une vieille
voiture qui a 30 ans et qu'on lui dit
bah tu dois faire moins de CO2 qu'une
voiture électrique, moins d'émission.
Donc c'est donc on va devoir revenir. Et
non seulement alors en Europe, c'est pas
forcément une mauvaise chose, parfois
c'est quand même une bonne chose, c'est
énorme. Ça nous a l'air longtemps
protégé sur l'industrie automobile par
rapport aux chinois. Donc c'était une
sorte de protectionnisme un peu déguisé.
Mais les normes européennes sont les
plus strictes au monde. Très bien. Mais
les normes françaises sont encore pire
puisque nous on aime bien l'avelé plus
blanc que blanc. Donc on va faire de la
surtransposition. elles vont être encore
plus drastiques que les normes
européennes. Donc on là, c'est là où on
se tire quand même une très belle
deuxème balle, voire on en met deux dans
chaque pied. Euh et tant qu'on ne fera
rien sur les normes de sérieux, euh il y
a pas grand-chose à attendre
malheureusement parce que n'importe quel
entrepreneur, n'importe quel industriel,
tu parlais de cet exemple de mine, mais
il y en a d'autres he des gens qui
veulent s'implanter euh même je me
souviens de cette usine qui voulait
faire des brioches en Bretagne. Dès
qu'on veut mettre une usine de toute
façon il y a tous les gens locaux alors
que c'est pourvoyeilleurs d'emploi un
emploi industriel il y a des emplois
indirects parfois c'est de 3 4 dans
l'industrie automobile c'est quatre
emplois en plus maintenant les gens sont
opposés c'est le syndrome not backyard
et donc les gens bah qu'est-ce qu'ils
font pas derrière mon jardin pas dans
mon jardin et donc les gens les gens
qu'est-ce qu'ils font bah ils partent
ailleurs dans un autre pays parce que
c'est juste trop compliqué Philippe
évoquait l'importance du lithium tout à
l'heure ce qui est tout à fait
juste un élément intéressant dit pas que
des conneries hein.
Un élément intéressant d'information et
de réflexion, en tout cas de réflexion
euh Exon Mobile, le géant pétrolier
américain Exon Valdez. Alors il y a
effectivement à l'époque c'était Exon,
c'était pas encore et puis après ils ont
absorbé mobile donc c'est devenu Exon
mobile. Mais effectivement oui, c'était
c'était bien eux en Alaska. Donc Exon
Mobile, le premier pétrolier américain
et le premier pétrolier privé
mondial décide en 2023 de se lancer dans
l'exploitation du lithium aux
États-Unis. Pour commencer, ils achètent
des terres dans l'état d'Arcansas, riche
en lithium et ils nous disent Michaon
mobile qui n'a fait que que entre
guillemets du pétrole et du gaz depuis
en gros 150 ans. Je vais commencer à
produire du lithium en 2027, c'està-dire
demain et en 2030, je produirai
suffisamment de lithium pour équiper 1
million de véhicules électriques par an.
Et ça c'est le début parce qu'après
j'irai plus loin. Saou Ramko, le géant
pétrolier saoudien, le géant pétrolier
mondial, société étatique, décide tout
récemment de se lancer dans le
lithium. Donc des pétroliers se disent
par rapport à la entre guillemets
transition énergétique, on va pas
forcément rentrer pour certains dans le
solaire ou dans l'éolien comme le font
certains pétroliers européens, Total
énergie BPCH. On va s'intéresser à la
transition entre guillemets en allant
dans le secteur minier et en développant
en exploitant des ressources minières
minerais métaux qui seront
indispensables pour cette transition.
Stratégie intéressante. Oui. Alors tout
à fait intéressante parce que bon moi
qui ai travaillé dans le Oui, on va je
lui rentre l'appareil. Euh moi qui ai
travaillé pendant pendant près de 43 ans
dans le pétrole et qui suis ingénieur
des mines, c'est vrai qu'il y a une
proximité entre un projet pétrolier, un
projet minier. C'est c'est un petit peu
c'est un petit peu la même chose. On
peut faire un peut faire un tas
d'analogies. Donc c'est tout à fait
c'est tout à fait logique. Maintenant,
on assiste quand même au cours des deux
dernières années à un recul complet des
grands majors pétroliers vis-à-vis de la
transition énergétique, hein. Tu
mentionnais juste maintenant Chelle
Total et BP. Euh total, oui, continue,
mais avec et je suis bien placé pour le
savoir, avec une sélectivité euh
renforcé sur les projets pour qu'ils
soient économiques. Chell de son côté
abandonne et l'éolien offshore et
l'éolien marin et quant à BP qui avait
dit j'investirai 10 milliards par an
dans les renouvelables et seulement 1
milliard par an dans le
pétrole à l'horizon 2030 vient
d'annoncer le contraire c'est-à-dire non
je fais marche arrière tout simplement
pourquoi parce que le capital des
compagnies pétrolières est
essentiellement détenu par les caisses
de retraite américaines qui veulent du
rendement et pour Votre information, un
projet renouvelable c'est entre 4 et 6 %
de retour sur investissement. Un projet
pétrolier gazier, c'est au minimum 15.
Et ce revirement de BP qui est tout
récent, qui remonte il y a quelques
semaines hein euh qui que Philippe
évoque à juste titre, il y a ce que tu
as indiqué, le mécontentement des
actionnaires de BP qui se tournent vers
la direction en disant bon c'est bien de
vouloir sauver le monde mais voilà nous
nos dividendes et cetera, les caisses de
retraite vieux les caisses de retraite
ont derrière eux les retraités qui
veulent du rendement parce que c'est de
la retraite par capitalisation donc le
retraité il n'a pas le il n'a
malheureusement pas l'État l'état l'État
derrière lui. Et il y a un autre facteur
par lequel nous avons commencé cette
émission, c'est Donald Trump. BP 40 % de
ses investissements mondiaux sont aux
États-Unis
et ils ont bien vu que le 20 janvier
2025, il y a un nouveau shérif à
Washington et qui n'a pas tout à fait la
même vision que son prédécesseur Joe
Biden par rapport à la entre guillemets
transition énergétique et par rapport
aux énergies fossiles. Donc ils prennent
cela en compte. Ils tiennent compte de
rapport de force. Philippe, tu veux
rajouter un mot avant de donner la
parole ? Non non, j'ai à peu près dit
tout ce que je voulais dire.
Donc moi, je les écoute. On est bien là.
Question pour vous trois. Euh pour vous,
quels sont les quatre pays européens les
plus dans la
moise concernant les ressources,
l'énergie et l'accès aux ressources ?
Oh moi je dirais le la Belgique est dans
une bon c'est un petit pays que je
connais bien. Oui, c'est un pays ou on
va pas annexer le côté français. Alors
le c'est vrai que la Belgique n'existe
que par rapport une volonté
d'émancipation par rapport à son voisin
du nord et son voisin du sud hein. Il
faut savoir que les Français les les
wallons sont des Français catholiques et
que les flamands sont des hollandais
catholiques. Voilà. Euh mais bon, ça
c'est un détail historique mais enfin de
temps en temps, c'est intéressant de
donc la Belgique est dans un est dans un
état de décomposition énergétique assez
inquiétant tout simplement parce que
elle avait 50 % d'électricité nucléaire
euh et qu'elle a arrêté euh pour des
raisons idéologiques la plupart de ses
réacteurs. C'est d'ailleurs NJ qui est
le l'opérateur de al qui s'appelle Tract
mais bon c'est NJ qui est qui est
l'opérateur. Et donc aujourd'hui, ils
veulent revenir vers le nucléaire et
remettre en route leurs centrales qui
ont été arrêtées. Mais malheureusement
NJ veut pas et c'est pas possible. Alors
la loi est en train est en train de
changer mais l'énergie c'est le temps
long et malheureusement ça ça ne
changera pas. La Belgique hier un disons
sur l'heure de midi avait beaucoup trop
de solaire devait l'évacuer et donc en
fait le le prix de l'électricité en
Belgique hier sur l'heure de midi était
à moins 450 €. Est-ce font comme les
Russes ils allument les lampadaires en
pleine journée ? Est-ce qu'ils font
comme les Russes allumer les lampadaires
en pleine journée ? Probablement oui.
Euh probablement c'est c'est les seuls
qui clair les autoroutes en Belgique
d'ailleurs. C'est ceux qui Mais je me
demande si alors ça peut continuer à
durer en fait avec le solaire, il
faudrait éclairer les autoroutes de la
journée. Des neiges qui répart les
trous. Voilà. Après euh je pense que
l'Allemagne est dans une position
énergétique absolument absolument
absolument épouvantable. l'Allemagne a
pareil hein décidé de euh d'arrêter son
son nucléaire. Voudrait maintenant y
revenir mais c'est pas Il y a d'ailleurs
un un alors c'est pas un pays européen
mais c'est intéressant, c'est que même
le Japon qui avait évidemment abandonné
le nucléaire à cause de Fukushima a
annoncé qu'ils allaient revenir vers le
nucléaire. Un troisème pays, l'Italie
n'est pas non plus je pense dans un dans
un dans un position très favorable. Elle
a notamment un réseau électrique assez
déficient. Et puis on peut quand même
rajouter l'Espagne, hein. Euh alors
l'Espagne était soi-disant euh un
miracle énergétique qui s'était retiré
de du système électrique européen et
cetera, ce qui est pas vrai du tout
d'ailleurs sur le sur le fond. et on a
vu que leur mix énergétique avec un
excès de renouvelable récemment pouvait
poser quelques petits problèmes. Alors,
on va attendre la commission d'enquête
et les résultats parce que sinon on va
nous accuser de faire en fait une une
instrumentalisation de ce de ce blackout
pour faire de l'antiR et du proucléaire.
Et du proucléaire. Absolument. Euh
Francis, quel pays ? Moi je le les pays
évoqués par Philippe, ça me semble un
bon choix. près Brexit aussi. J'ai pas
passé en revue tous les 27 mais oui
Belgique, Allemagne, Italie
effectivement pensé j'étais en train de
chercher le 4e mais Espagne Portugal
parce que le Portugal et l'Espagne du
point de vue électrique ils sont ils
sont complètement complètement liés.
Donc donc j'irai tout à fait dans ce
sens-là. Ben moi je je mettrai peut-être
parce qu'en fait il y a différentes
énergies he il y a le pétrole, il y a le
gaz. Alors, c'est vrai qu'avant il y en
avait qui était sur le pétrole, il y en
a il y a quand même un pays qui est très
gâté, c'est la Norvège que ce soit en
ressources hydraulique ou en pétrole
voir en gaz. Je croyais que c'était
l'Union européenne donc Oui oui, c'est
pour ça. Mais il est pas dans l'Union
européenne. Moi je parle de ceux qui
sont gâtés. On avait les Pays-Bas qui
étaient assez assez gâtés aussi mais eux
ils ont fermé leur dernier champ de gaz.
Prod encore un petit peu de gaz sur
Grening encore un peu de gaz. Trop de
tremblement de terre. Euh voilà qu'ils
avaient qu'on avait d'ailleurs remplacé
par du gaz du gaz russe à partir de
2014. Euh en fait on a un problème sur
l'électricité je pense. Et là on
commence à s'en rendre compte. C'est
vrai que étant donné ce qui s'est passé
en Espagne, personnellement j'ai passé
un petit peu de temps à regarder les
données et on a de la chance parce
qu'elles sont accessibles à tout le
monde. Vous allez sur le site Eodomix
the RTE, vous pouvez voir des choses
vous pouvez voir les échanges, vous
pouvez voir la production mais ça c'est
que pour la France. Alors, il y a un
autre site qui s'appelle Energy Charts
et là, c'est fait par un allemand et là,
on a toutes les infos pour tous les mix,
tous les pays d'Europe. On voit un peu
ce qui se passe. Et moi, ça me rappelle
une note qu'on a publié avec France
Stratégie en janvier 2021. J'étais pas
d'ailleurs auteur de cette note et où on
disait attention euh l'électricité c'est
quelque chose qui se stock mal mais qui
se transporte très bien. Donc quand on
parle d'électricité on parle pas d'un
pays en fait, on parle d'une plaque, on
parle de l'Europe. Euh sauf que on parle
de l'Europe mais que chacun décide dans
son coin. Donc nous, on avait pointé à
l'époque d'ailleurs un risque plutôt
dans l'autre sens qui était un risque de
pénurie notamment, c'est-à-dire de
blackout mais lié à pas assez
d'électricité en hiver parce qu'en fait
on a fermé beaucoup de moyens de moyens
pilotables comme des centrales à gaz,
des centrales à charbon voir des
centrales nucléaires en comptant sur les
voisins. On compte sur les voisins. Donc
au lieu de garder une centrale qui va
tourner que quelques heures par an, ben
on va faire tourner
l'interconnexion avec la Belgique, avec
l'Allemagne, avec la Suisse. Sauf que
quand on arrive dans une situation où
tout le monde a besoin de des voisins,
c'est là où on a un problème. Alors, on
a été on a eu cette contrainte en 2022
quand on a eu la les problèmes sur nos
réacteurs nucléaires. Maintenant, ça va
mieux et entre guillemets, ça va mieux
aussi parce qu'en fait, on a beaucoup
détruit de demande. Alors, bien
évidemment, on a tous suivi les conseils
d'anies panier runaché en se chauffant à
19°. les conseils de Bruno Lemire en
étendant éteignant notre boxe en partant
en vacances et mettre un col roulé et
mettre un col roulé euh mais là on voit
qu'on a on est dans un autre problème un
autre régime de problème qui est plutôt
lié à la surproduction mais que soit sur
l'électricité qu'on soit en
sous-production pas assez d'électricité
pour la consommation ou en surproduction
trop d'électricité pour la consommation
c'est le même problème et ça peut avoir
les mêmes conséquences de blackout et là
quand on regarde les capacités cité
installé de de solaire. Je regardais ça
l'autre jour, moi-même je n'y croyais
pas. En Europe, je crois que c'est on a
presque multiplié par de en 4 ans, 5 ans
depuis 2020 les capacités installées de
solaires. Je le disais tout à l'heure à
Philippe, en Allemagne aujourd'hui, vous
pouvez voir ça sur le site Ennergy Chart
aujourd'hui ou ils étaient à
l'équivalent de 45 réacteurs nucléaires
de solaire. On était à 45 GW. Tu connais
les capacités solaires de la Chine ? Euh
non mais je connais celle de l'Allemagne
mais la ils produisent 1 ter 1 ter un je
vais dire non un un ptawur par an
d'électricité solaire donc 1000 TWh par
an d'électricité solaire et on doit être
à 300 GW je crois peut-être un peu plus
je sais pas peut-être un peu moins.
Peut-être un peu moins. C'est l'ordre de
grand l'Allemagne par exemple 300
centrales nucléaires d' Oui. Alors enfin
oui 300 centrales nucléaires en en terme
de puissance en terme de puissance
effective sauf qu'il faut diviser par 4
parce que le facteur de charge est de 25
% donc ça fait quand même sauf que sauf
que il faut qu'on évacue. En terme de
production c'est pas pareil. à midie, on
doit évacuer cette énergie. Et donc là,
on le voit typiquement le tous les
weekends parce que le weekend en Europe,
on est plutôt chez soi à se relaxer que
dans l'usine, à bosser, même dans les
quelques usines qui restent. Et donc ben
on voit qu'on a un gros problème parce
que à l'heure du déjeuner euh il y a pas
de il y a peu de consommation et donc on
sait pas quoi faire de cette
électricité. Euh et donc alors on peut
toujours couper les parcs les parcs
solaires hein, mais euh finalement on
est en abondance d'électricité. Ce qui
fait quoi ? Et ce qui fait que le
principal problème dont j'aimerais bien
parler, c'est qu'en Europe, en fait, on
veut absolument faire la transition
énergétique. Et l'enjeu aujourd'hui,
c'est l'électrification des usages. Il
faut électrifier les usages. Il faut
remplacer les énergies
fossiles dans le chauffage, par des
pompes à chaleur, dans le transport, par
des voitures électriques. Sauf que la
solution qu'on a trouvé pour le faire
mécaniquement fait multiplier le prix de
l'électricité par deux. Donc en fait, on
demande aux gens en gros euh de
consommer plus, de payer plus pour pour
le même enfin ça n'arrive nulle part en
fait. Il y a personne à quel argent. Il
y a personne qui va alors on s'étonne
oui ben on comprend pas la consommation
baisse. En fait ça s'appelle
l'élasticité prix hein. Quand le prix
augmente la consommation baisse. Donc ça
un enfant de 5 ans peut comprendre mais
ça visiblement les dirigeants européens
ils ont du mal à donc moi je veux bien
électrifier les usages. Je suis pour me
passer au maximum du pétrole et du gaz
qu'on importe mais avec une solution qui
est compétitive où les gens ça va leur
coûter moins cher d'avoir leur usage
électrifié plutôt que plus cher parce
que sinon il y a aucune chance d'y
arriver. Donc aujourd'hui je pense pas
qu'on est misé sur le bon cheval. On
revient sur mon mon parc de réacteur de
60 réacteurs qu'il faut utiliser au
maximum et cetera.
Parce que là aujourd'hui, si vous voulez
les énergies renouvelables, c'est ça qui
est quand même fortement contribué à
multiplier par de notre prix électricité
en 10 ans. Et encore, on n pas assez
payé parce que c'est ce qu'ils disent en
Espagne pour l'instant ce que disent les
autorités c'est ça n'est pas la faute
des renouvelables. C'est parce que nous
avons pas assez investi dans le réseau.
Bon, on comprendra ce qu'on veut mais
grosso modo, bah c'est juste que ces
énergies là, en plus de les mettre, il
faut prévoir du stockage parce que sans
stockage, on n'est pas capable
d'équilibrer notre réseau. Donc, on a
fait une partie du chemin, mais sauf que
si on fait la deuxième partie du chemin,
ben ça va forcément faire augmenter les
prix et si on fait augmenter les prix,
bah on va moins en consommer, donc on va
pas réussir à électrifier. Donc, on est
un peu sur un serpent qui se manque la
queue et pour l'instant on n pas trouvé,
on n pas réussi à à trouver la solution
à cette équation. Avant que Philippe
rebondisse, oui, que Francis rebondisse,
juste une question. Les Anglais, ils
sont en quel état énergétique ? Ah, ils
ont l'avantage d'encore produire du
pétrole et du gaz. Ça c'est quand même
déjà un avantage. Alors, c'est en c'est
en déclin, mais bon, malgré tout, ils
ont un avantage compétitif historique
par rapport aux autres qui est qui est
assez important. Euh, ils ont un mix
électrique qui est assez intéressant
parce que il est assez euh assez assez
équilibré et pragmatique. Donc, je
dirais que euh c'est parmi ceux qui s'en
sortent pas mal.
Et puisqu'on est en dehors de l'Union
européenne, même si c'est tout proche,
tu évoquais tout à l'heure Nicolas la
Norvège qui est le principal producteur
de pétrole et de gaz naturel dans
l'Europe, l'Europe occidentale, pas
seulement l'Union européenne. Et alors
que la production d'hydrocarbure du
Royaume-Uni diminue, la production de la
Norvège reste stable en terme de pétrole
et de gaz. Et donc ce pays tire profit
du pétrole et du gaz national, notamment
du Nord, mer de Norvège, mer de Barens
et cetera. C'est surtout une production
offshore et en même temps il se lance à
fond dans la transition mais il je
dirait il profite des deux côtés hein de
c'est pas parce qu'il se dit voilà moi
je suis un pays vert je suis un pionnier
en terme de véhicule électrique qu'il
abandonne les hydrocarbures parce qu'il
sait très bien ce qu'il doit aux
hydrocarbures en terme de richesse
nationale. avant l'hydrocarbure, la
Norvège n'était pas le pays qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui avec un niveau de
vie nettement plus élevé que les les
pays européens. Et pour rebondir sur ce
que disait Nicolas tout à l'heure, sur
le coût par rapport à la transition, euh
Nicolas évoquait, c'est un point très
important, l'Union
européenne. Euh transposons ça à des
pays en développement, la France
de de vrais pays en développement, pas
la Chine, hein, des vrais pays en
développement. Est-ce que comment est-ce
que ces pays peuvent entre guillemets se
payer la transition énergétique
? Ils font comme nous avec les galeries
à fillett, ils bavent devant la vitrine.
Il ils ne le font pas. Voilà. Pourquoi
est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup plus de
projets
solaires au Moyen-Orient qu'en Afrique
? Tu as donné la réponse, le capital.
Et c'est pas qu'il y a pas de soleil en
Afrique en terme de rayonnement solaire,
c'est pas qu'il y a pas de
l'espace, mais le coût certes, le soleil
on ne le paye pas, le vent ne le pai
pas, mais le coût d'investissement de
centrales solairire de parc éolien,
c'est très cher à l'investissement. Les
pays arabes du golf avec la rente
pétrolière et gazière ont le rayonnement
solaire très élevé évidemment, l'espace
superfici et le capital avec l'argent du
pétrole et du gaz.
Si ils ont tous les atouts, si je
comprends bien, pas de pognon, pas de
transition énergétique. Les
investissement dans les redouvelables
depuis 15 ans, c'est quand même 15000
milliards de dollars ont été investis.
C'est c'est c'est une paille. Répondre
aux besoins énergétiques mondiaux et
faire la transition, en tout cas essayer
de la faire, c'est des milliers de
milliards de dollars d'investissement
énergétique par an.
Tu crois qu'on va y arriver ? Non.
pas au rythme annoncé, pas en 2050.
Voilà, genre en
2350 on aura développer les les voyages
interstelles, les orbitations pour faire
de l'explosion minière et alors El Musk
peut-être nous enverra tous vers Mars.
Enfin, peut-être pas tous parce que on
n'est pas assez intelligent pour lui. On
n peut-être pas assez riche et pas assez
fortuné. Moi, je voulais revenir sur la
pronon le maire sur Mars. Ça devrait
être intéressant. Non, il y a pas des
finances à faire là-bas ?
Des économies à écrouler. Des économies
à écouer. Ouais, pas mal. Je voulais
écrouler l'économie martienne. Je
voulais je voulais revenir sur ce que ce
que Nicolas évoquer, c'est-à-dire la
l'électrification des usages parce qu'en
fait la base de la transition
énergétique, elle est là, c'est de
remplacer des équipements thermiques par
des équipements électriques puisque les
équipements électriques avec de
l'électricité décarbonée n'émettent pas
de n'émettent pas de
CO2 CO2. Voilà. Mais donc ça seulement
qu'une question d'énergie, c'est aussi
une question d'équipement. Donc
c'est-à-dire ce qu'il a évoqué, les
voitures électriques, c'est pas de
l'énergie hein, c'est un équipement, euh
les euh les pompes à chaleur et puis
également les comment par exemple
l'hydrogène dans l'industrie, c'est un
exemple aussi de un exemple aussi
d'équipements différents. On va euh
séparer euh la réduction du minera de la
de la fonte du du minerai. Et donc, on
nous a malheureusement vendu ces
équipements comme des équipements
universels alors qu'ils ne le sont pas.
Donc, c'est-à-dire que que ce soit la
voiture électrique, je vais prendre
l'exemple de la voiture électrique et de
la pompe à chaleur parce que ce sont
deux exemples qui sont assez assez
intéressant. C'est que on sait que la
voiture électrique c'est ça marche assez
bien euh comme urbaine, comme péri
urbaine, voir comme campagnarde, mais
que c'est pas fait du tout pour soit les
grandes villes comme Paris parce que on
peut pas charger. J'ai demandé
l'autorisation de monter dans
l'ascenseur à une voiture électrique
pour la charger dans mon appartement. Ça
été malheureusement refusé par le par le
syndique. Euh était belge, ils ont
compris. Ah oui. Absolument. Et euh par
contre ça marche pas non plus pour
disons que c'est compliqué pour les
longues distances et en plus c'est très
coûteux parce que la voiture électrique,
tu me corrigeras Nicolas, c'est à peu
près euh 30 40 % plus cher qu'une
voiture thermique. Voiture thermique
équivalente. Ça dépend si est chinoise
ou pas. Voilà. pompe à chaleur son taxe.
La pompe à chaleur, pareil, la pompe à
chaleur marchait essentiellement bien
plutôt dans les régions du sud de la
France, donc les régions où les
variations de température sur l'année ne
sont pas trop élevées. Et puis ça
marche, ça on le sait peu. Très mal pour
un chauffage ponctuel des radiateurs. Ça
marche bien pour un chauffage au sol
puisque on attaque
la l'enveloppe, le radiateur à une
température beaucoup plus faible avec un
chauffage au sol qu'avec qu'avec des
radiateurs. Donc avec des radiateurs, on
a un rendement absolument épouvantable
et des notes d'électricité absolument
épouvantables. Et donc, on nous a vendu
ces solutions comme des solutions
universelles. Tout ménage français allit
avoir une voiture électrique, avoir une
pompe à chaleur. Et on voit
qu'aujourd'hui malheureusement
l'électrification des usages ne se fait
pas ou ne se fait pas au rythme annoncé.
Et donc effectivement, on a complètement
surdimensionné disons les capacités
électriques par rapport à
l'électrification des usages et on
semble continuer à vouloir le faire
puisqu'on veut multiplier le solaire en
France par 5 he je crois dans la dans la
PPE. C'est quand même juste une seconde
là-dessus. C'est quand même important
parce que qu'est-ce qui se passe ? On a
des centrales solaires en France.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe le weekend ? Ce
qui se passe le weekend, c'est qu'il y
en a encore plus chez notre voisin
allemand. Donc pour pouvoir absorber
l'électricité solaire allemande, 45 GW,
on coupe les nôtres, d'accord ? On coupe
nos centrales, nous on a 15 GW, je
crois, si je dis pas de bêtises, pour
pouvoir absorber. On en envoie une
partie aussi vers l'Espagne. Et donc
alors qu'on coupe les notes et qu'on a
15 GW ou 15 20 GW, la PPE c'est d'en
mettre 80 90.
Aujourd'hui, on est déjà en
surproduction. Euh, on voit pas vraiment
on voit pas vraiment les sign avec tout
ça. Comment exactement du Bitcoin ?
Ouais. Oui, c'est ça. Euh et donc moi je
le le grand message ça n'est pas qu'il
faut arrêter la décarbonation, qu'il
faut arrêter le solaire et l'éolien,
mais il faut complètement détendre
l'agenda. il faut complètement détendre
l'agenda et euh ne plus viser ces encore
une fois ces objectifs d'agenda inversé
qui n'ont absolument aucun sens du type
2035 et 2050 parce qu'on sait que de
toute façon euh bon tu parlais de 350
ans, on va pas aller jusque là mais je
crois que si euh la fin des fossiles, je
ne suis pas sûr qu'elle sera en 2100. En
tout cas, elle ne sera pas en 2050. en
2050, on aura encore au moins 50 % de
fossil si pas plus dans le mix
énergétique mondial. Comment ? Mais à
quel prix ? Ah ben ça ça dépend si on
continue ou pas à développer.
C'est-à-dire que globalement si on si on
arrêtait aujourd'hui de développer les
champs pétroliers et qu'on se
contentait de
l'existant, l'existant il décline à peu
près naturellement entre 4 et 6 % par
an. Donc ce qui veut dire que dans euh 3
ans euh il y a une rupture offre-demande
complète et on a un baril d'à 500
dollars. Si on continue à développer les
champs comme c'est souhaitable et
inévitable mais que refusent évidemment
certains écologistes qui disent il faut
arrêter tout investissement dans le
développement et la recherche de
nouveaux champs pétrolier à ce moment-là
on peut pensé un peu. Comment tu penses
pas au bébé fo ? Moi, je pense avant
tout au développement humain. Je suis un
grand défenseur du développement humain
et je dois dire que c'est peut-être un
tort, mais que le développement humain
est indissociable de l'énergie et de la
production de richesse. Et donc, sans
produire de richesse et sans avoir
d'énergie, ça veut dire renoncer au
développement humain. Je ne suis pas
prêt pour l'instant à jeter le bébé avec
l'eau du bain. Rappelons-nous quand même
que l'espérance de vie sous l'air
napoléonienne, c'était 35 ans. On est
passé aujourd'hui à 75 80 ans. Pour
certains, c'est pas un progrès. Pour
moi, ça est un. Francis,
on était bien sous Napoléon. Non,
ça dépend en quelle année. Quand on
essayer c'était quand même quand on
essayé d'aller à Moscou,
on a essayé, on n'est pas arrivé du pas
y aller, ça allait, c'est revenir qui a
été le problème effectivement. Oui,
c'est Non, mais il y a un mot qu'il faut
réhabiliter, c'est le
réalisme. Ce n'est pas un mot honteux,
ça veut dire regarder la réalité en
face. Réalisme ou pragmatisme ?
Je je prends les deux mots
volontiers. On est quand même un pays
très
idéologique. Alors, c'est bienin, c'est
voilà, c'est ça donne des débats
passionnants et cetera. Bon, mais on
touche pas terre. L'énergie c'est du
concret, du solide. On a les pieds dans
le sol et même souvent dans le sous-sol,
hein, à 80 % quand mêmeon a 80 % au
moins d'énergie fossile dans la
consommation mondiale d'énergie. Donc
voilà, c'est pas de grands débats
philosophicaux, métaphysicaux,
religiosaux, je sais pas quoi. C'est du
concret.
Et euh si les faits sont têtus, comme on
dit en français hein et aucun être
humain n'est plus têtu que les
faits. Ainsi, il y a Bruno
Lemer et Emmanuel Macron, ils sont
têtus. Têtu ou aveugle ou borgne ou mal
conseillé.
Euh alors, il peut y avoir un problème
par rapport au conseillers qui entourent
ces personnes. C'est vrai que euh je
vais simplifier un peu, mais si vous
avez autour de vous en tant que
responsable politique des conseillers
qui vont tous dans le même sens, une
cour ? Alors, une cour déjà ça c'est un
problème parce qu'on vous reste dans le
sens du poil, mais même sans aller
jusque là, des conseillers qui vont tous
dans le même sens parce qu'ils ont la
même vision.
Euh c'est bien d'avoir autour de soi des
gens qui vous disent pas toujours la
même
chose. Et ensuite c'est au politique
évidemment de faire son miel de tout ça,
de prendre la décision. Euh mais voilà
qui par qui vous êtes
entouré. Euh est-ce qu'il n'hésite pas à
vous dire des choses qui sont parfois
désagréables ? Est-ce qu'ils n'ont pas
tous le même point de vue, la même
vision
? Est-ce qu'il y a dans leur vision 100
% d'idéologie, 90 % 80 % 10 % et cetera
? Donc et puis quel courage politique
des autorités qui à la fin du fin
doivent prendre des décisions et peuvent
pas dire c'est de la faute de mon
conseiller ou de ma conseillère.
Nicolas, en général quand quand qu'on
est conseiller de politique, le
politique il aime bien, passe-moi
l'expression, mais la lèche
ben j'ai eu j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir
côtoyer d'assez loin, mais un peu côtoyé
quand même quand j'étais à France
Stratégie, certains conseillers
ministériels et et c'est là que je pense
que c'est là où on a un très gros
problème dont on se rend pas forcément
compte et c'est vrai que
Les ministres, je pense, sont assez mal
entourés et sont entourés par des gens
qui sont là pour leur dire ce qui leur
fait plaisir et qui passent un peu sous
la table le reste. Donc typiquement
quand vous avez un rapport qui est fait
par
l'administration, plus il remonte, plus
on enlève ce qui fâche et donc à la fin
on leur explique Brunon Lemire, tu es le
meilleur. Et c'était pas ça ce qui était
dans le rapport au départ. Et donc on a
un vrai souci de filtre en fait. Alors
et et et une fois de plus, on je pense
que c'est un petit peu tout le système.
Alors je sais pas c'est lié aux écoles
sur Polena, mais en fait on fabrique des
gens qui sont tous dans le même moule.
Euh et moi j'avais vu ça, j'avais vu un
documentaire qui était fait sur euh qui
était fait sur qui est passé sur France
2 avec Emmanuel Macron qui s'appelle un
président moi méchant. Non, c'était
presque ça mais un président l'Europe et
la guerre et c'était assez intéressant
de voir ça et quand on le voyait il
était comme ça à faire ses ses
stratégies puis il était dans son je
voyais un avion qui allait à Strasbourg
au Bruxelles. Il disait "Ah regarde, il
avait 10 personnes autour de lui, "Ah,
on va faire ça, on va faire ça et
cetera. Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?"
Et tout le monde lui disait que c'était
génial.
s'il y a pas de contradiction, s'il y a
personne pour lui dire "On n'est pas là
pour se fâcher, on n'est pas là pour lui
apporter les éléments qui lui permettent
lui de réfléchir et de décider." Et je
pense qu'effectivement il y a un vrai
phénomène de cours que ce soit bien sûr
au palais à l'Élysée que ce soit dans
les dans les ministères et ça avait été
d'ailleurs très bien dit par Yve Brcher
qui était d'ailleurs venu ici sur Swit
que bonjour d'ailleurs. Voilà qui disait
que lui les rapports qu'il faisait s'ils
étaient reliés des deux côtés ça
changeait pas grand-chose. Moi j'ai eu
la même expérience quand j'étais à
France Stratégie. Donc on est si vous
voulez, il y a des très bonnes
administrations, il faut dire des gens
qui travaillent très bien, qui font des
du super boulot mais en fait tout est
filtré. Ça n'arrive pas ça n'arrive pas
jusqu'en haut. C'est bloqué. C'est comme
si c'était bouché, c'est bloqué. Genre
une question vous vous qui êtes dans la
partie depuis un certain nombre de
décennies, on voit ça sur l'énergie, on
a l'impression qu'ils sont mal
conseillés, mal entourés, qu'il y a un
phénomène de cours. Euh ça doit être la
même chose pour la géopolitique, pour la
géostratégie, les guerre économiqu
la France.
On est un petit peu dans la panade là.
On avait vu du temps de pompidou, du
temps de de
goule thermonucléaire sortir en combien
d'années ? 6 ans. 7 ans ? 6 ans. Est-ce
qu'il faudrait pas maintenant euh qu'on
se réveille nous français et belges en
se disant bon maintenant on a fait le
constat, les Chinois vont nous manger
industriellement parlant sont en train
de lancer
25000 gw de projets que les Américains
font la même chose et que nous on va
rester au milieu du gay avec les bébés
fog Gretberg et on sera tous contents
d'observer notre batterie qui sera pas
médine France.
Est-ce qu'il faut pas saisir nos
députés, nos sénateurs en leur disant
maintenant on va à la mort cérébrale,
économique et industrielle de la France
si on ne développe pas nos énergies ?
Mais qu'est-ce qu'ils peuvent faire les
députés les sénateurs ? Ben déjà arrêter
euh se réveiller. Philippe, les députés
et les sénateurs, ils sont ils sont
malheureusement euh ce sont des
soldats aux ordres aux ordres aux ordres
du général. Donc
euh on a on a quand même un système
français aussi
où ce que je veux dire extrêmement euh
extrêmement hiérarchique, extrêmement
euh dominateur et vertical euh qui
n'existe pas dans je crois que les pays
nordiques s'en débrouillent beaucoup
mieux bien queon pourrait parler de la
Suède qui en matière de transition
énergétique est un peu l'exemple de tout
ce qu'il ne faut pas faire depuis depuis
une dizaine d'années Euh de toute façon,
l'indépendance énergétique, on ne l'aura
jamais puisqu'on ne produira ni pétrole
ni
gaz. Je pense que il y a certain nombre
de filières qui peuvent qui peuvent nous
apporter des choses. Les par exemple
tout ce qui est bio peut peut-être nous
apporter un certain nombre de choses.
Bien que ça reste assez coûteux. Donc ce
qui est biocarburant, biogaz et cetera,
la filière nucléaire reste quand même,
c'est très important parce que euh dans
le MAW dans le MW nucléaire, les
investissements, c'est-à-dire le coût de
la centrale qui est quand même construit
sur le territoire compte pour 95 % et le
prix de l'uranium pour 5 %. Donc ça veut
dire que ça pour les conditions
actuelles. Ouais. Mais bon, de toute
façon, ça restera ça restera un business
de d'investissement et pas un business
de fonctionnement comparé à des
centrales à gaz ou des centrales à
charbon où le prix du gaz et du charbon
euh peut jouer jusqu'à 80 % du prix du
prix du MWAWh. Donc je crois que on est
devant, on est c'est vrai, non seulement
au milieu du gay, mais en face d'un
certain nombre
d'orientation qu'il est peut-être encore
temps de prendre un certain nombre de
décisions en matière énergétique, mais
j'ai malheureusement l'impression que ça
ne va pas dans le bon sens et que le
politicien refusant d'accepter qu'il
s'est trompé et de revenir en arrière
euh aura beaucoup de mal à se remettre
en question. Quand on voit le discours,
le fameux discours de Bfort de Macron où
il revient à il tourne à 180° puisque
avant le discours de Bfort, on devait
fermer 14 réacteurs nucléaires. Après le
discours de Bfort, on doit en construire
14 nouveaux. Donc pour faire environment
180°, on peut pas faire mieux. Si
s'appelle Gerhouette. Voilà. Et quand on
lui dit quand on lui dit donc vous avez
changé, vous êtes trompé. Ah non, j'ai
rien changé. J'ai toujours dit la même
chose. Comment voulez-vous évoluer avec
des raisonnements pareils ? pas
possible.
Francis Nicolas, la mol épinière du cap
de la girouette, de la politique de GP
le l'urgence,
le la réaction et pas forcément
l'anticipation. Évidemment, c'est
l'anticipation, c'est plus facile à dire
qu'à faire mais c'est quand même
gouverner, c'est prévoir hein, comme
disait déjà Pierre Mandz France, je
crois le son âme le grand programme
nucléaire français. Bon, la France était
lancée déjà dans le nucléaire, mais le
grand programme nucléaire français,
c'est une réaction au premier choc
pétrolier, fin 73 début 74. Et pendant
des dizaines d'années, nous avons eu des
gouvernements très différents au début
de droite, François Mitteran à partir
1981, qui n'ont pas remis en cause parce
que sous prétexte c'était fait par ceux
d'avant en disant on pense que c'est
dans l'intérêt national de la
France et ça a duré quelques décennies
jusqu'à ce que dans une époque un peu
moins inspirée, certains se disent "Bon
ben maintenant finalement le nucléaire
on va le faire décroître." Donc on
commence par fermer deux réacteurs
Fenheim et après on en fermera une
quinzaine. Euh voilà avant le
retournement du début 2022. Euh nous
l'avons dit à plusieurs reprises,
l'énergie c'est pas du court terme,
c'est à peine du moyen terme, c'est du
long terme, c'est du très long terme. Et
donc il faut avoir cette il faudrait
avoir cette vision de long terme et se
dire voilà, c'est pas parce que c'est
pas moi qui a décidé ça que c'est
mauvais si c'est dans l'intérêt national
de la France.
Non mais l'intérêt national de la France
Francis pour quand tu vois quand tu vois
Alstom quand tu vois les sell pour nos
missiles M51 partir chez les Chinois
quand tu vois technique quand tu vois
tout ça je te reprends juste une je te
la formule gouvernée ses prévoir est
attribuée à Émile de Girardin
journaliste et homme politique français
du 19e siècle il l'a écrit en 1852 dans
un article du journal La Presse. La la
citation complète est gouverner ses
prévoir et ne rien prévoir c'est courir
à sa perte. Et oui, citation
intéressante et donc nous grâce soit
rendu à Girard. J'aimerais peut-être
faire compléter ce que disait
Francis. Petite anecdote he quand même
sur le nucléaire notamment en Europe.
Comment est-ce qu'on en est arrivé là ?
J'aime bien rappeler que alors la
décision de sortir du nucléaire ne date
pas de de 2011 et d'Angela Merkel, mais
date de Guérard Schroder de 1998 et des
élections où il a besoin pour faire la
coalition des écolos, des verrs
allemands qui représentent 6 % des voix,
6 millions de votes, je sais jamais 6 %
des voies et 3 millions de votes. Et
donc pour avoir ces 6 % et devenir
chancelier, il promet la sortie du
nucléaire en 20 ans. Donc il dit bah
voilà en 2020, on sort du nucléaire.
Donc c'est la ce système démocratique
qui permet cette sortie du nucléaire ce
qu'on aurait pas sans doute eu dans
d'autres dans d'autres régimes. François
Hollande quand il annonce la sortie du
nucléaire c'est juste de manière
opportuniste, si je dis pas de bêtises
en juin 2011 3 ans après Fukushima,
juste pour récupérer les voies des
écolos et d'ailleurs c'est grâce à ces
voix-là qui devient président en 2012.
Donc c'est juste dans une pure logique
électoraliste. Euh et malheureusement,
on voit que l'intérêt de la France passe
derrière. Bah de deux autres exemples.
Je vais revenir à la Belgique puisqu'on
est exactement à la même période où le
gouvernement libéral he pourtant donc
gouvernement de centre droit euh n'a pas
la majorité s'associe aux écologistes en
donc on est de nouveau en 20012002 et
c'est là que se signe le la mort du
nucléaire belge où donc il s'engage à ne
plus construire de nouveaux réacteurs et
à fermer les réacteurs existants au plus
tard en 2025 donc maintenant et puis
bien avant En Hollande, on a quand même
le gouvernement Jospin euh avec madame
Voinet en 2000 en 2001 de 98 2000 2003
jusque l'élection de Chirak c'est 2000
non 2002 pardon c'est 2002 euh où
effectivement Jospin suicide sur l'hôtel
écolo Super Phenniix donc c'est-à-dire
cétait fait un peu avant lui hein il me
semble alors Super Phenniix avait du
plomb dans l'a c'est vrai ça
fonctionnait pas très bien il y a eu
beaucoup de choses avant mais enfin la
décision d'arrêter superfénique c'est
quand même voinet et Josep donc ça veut
dire que globalement c'est ce que je dis
toujours he les
écologistes sont un impolitique mais ont
un pouvoir absolument exacerbé sur sur
l'énergie tu l'as démontré avec les 6 %
de
de d'écol qui ont décidé de fermer les
d'abandonner le nucléaire de la première
puissance européenne ce qui aboutit à la
construction de Nordstream. On reproche
beaucoup à Guérard Schroder d'avoir dans
mais il a été obligé de faire dans
stream pour remplacer pour remplacer les
réacteurs nucléaires. Savoir qu'après il
a travaillé pour Gazprom et que il est
devenu directeur de Norstream. avec elle
peut-être mais je ne veux pas être au
départ
les Allemands quand ils ferment quand
ils décide de fermer le nucléaire ils
font deux choses un ils construisent ces
tuyaux pour avoir accès du gaz bon
marché et deux ils remettent ils
reconstruisent des centrales nucléaires
des centrales pardon à charbon à partir
de de 2005 de 2005 à 2010 pour les
remplacer donc il faut aujourd'hui je
dis
souvent si les Allemands avaient
conservé leur nucléaire ils
n'utiliseraient pas une goutte entre
guill guillemets de gaz dans la
production d'électricité probablement un
tout petit peu parce qu'il est en
messieur j'ai une question à vous poser.
Si je dois annoncer à mes ouailles en
tant que président vous me conseillez de
leur dire décroissance subie ou sobriété
heureuse ? Aucun des deux.
Philippe il dit aucun des deux. Francis
?
Aucun des deux non plus.
Tu triches là. Je suis d'accord avec
Philippe.
Non mais je pense que il faut dire les
choses telles qu'elles sont. La
situation dans laquelle on est et après
il faut surtout avoir un projet en fait.
Si le projet accessoirement pour
l'instant c'est le suicide, bah c'est
pas un projet qui est très qui va
emballer les Français. Qu'il faut
trouver un projet alternatif au projet
européen du suicide collectif en 2050.
Question internet. Quel est le risque de
ne plus être approvisionné en énergie
entre parenthèses pétrole, gaz, uranium
et dans le cas d'une rupture
d'approvisionnement, quelles sont les
ressources naturelles dont nous
disposons en Europe et qui permettraient
de satisfaire la demande actuelle en
énergie à l'avenir pour l'interrogation
des croissances subies et soudaine.
Alors, je dirais qu'en pétrole, moi, il
y a pas beaucoup de risque, hein, parce
que le pétrole ça circule sur tous les
océans. Il suffit de le payer et de
l'acheter quand je quand avec des euros,
des dollars. Oui.
Quand je travaillais en quand je
travaillais dans une autre vie en Angola
que j'approvisionnais un pétrolier en
Angola, il circulait entre Luanda et
Rotterdam et il changeait 20 fois de
propriété. la carcaison changé 20 fois
de propriétaire entre les entre les deux
destinations. Donc ça veut dire que il y
a
aucune aucun indicateur aujourd'hui qui
annonce la pénurie et la possibilité du
pétrole. Pour le gaz, c'est plus
compliqué bien que avec l'augmentation
du gaz naturel liquéfié, le gaz naturel
liquéfié, on revient au cas du pétrole.
Autant avec du gaz par gaz auc, ben il y
a un point un point de départ, un point
d'arrivée et on peut pas les changer. Je
vous ai dit que pour euh euh
reconstruire des pipes, c'était des
affaires de de plusieurs années voire de
d'une dizaine d'années. Donc ça veut
dire qu'avec le marché mondial du gaz
naturel liquéfié, je suis pas très
inquiet non plus sur le sur le sur le
gaz, mais tout ça nous coûtera tout ça
nous coûtera plus cher que les autres,
plus cher à nos industries. Et donc
malgré tout ça ça a malheureusement des
effets
économiques déplorables. Mais tant qu'on
aura les moyens de payer le gaz, le
pétrole et l'électricité, il y en aura.
Et il y a quand même une grosse
différence entre le pétrole et
l'électricité, c'est que le prix du
pétrole, il est quand même capé. C'estàd
qu'il peut pas augmenter au-delà de
probablement 150 dollars ou peut-être un
petit peu moins. On l'avait vu. Alors,
je rappelle en passant que 100 dollars
le baril de pétrole ça coûte rien. Ça
coûte moins cher que de l'eau minéral
parce que je rappelle que quand vous
faites le plein d'essence, la plus
grande partie de ce que vous donnez,
c'est pour l'État, c'est pas pour le
pétrole. Euh donc 1 L d'essence, c'est
50 centimes. Euh mais donc le prix du
pétrole, il peut augmenter. Là, il est à
60 65, il peut peut-être monter à 80
90, mais il ira pas beaucoup plus parce
qu'en fait il est le même pour tout le
monde et donc à partir du moment où il
est trop élevé, bah ceux qui ont le
moins les moyens, ils essaient d'en
acheter, ils roulent moins, ils prennent
plus le vélo et donc la demande baisse
et donc le prix baisse. C'est pas le cas
sur le gaz naturel qui est entre
guillemets le pétrole, c'est pour des
consommateurs, pour leur voiture et
cetera. Le gaz naturel, oui, il y a du
chauffage, mais aussi c'est entre
guillemets une énergie pour les
entreprises B2B, donc pour euh pour la
fabrique production d'électricité, pour
les industriel et on l'a vu là, ben
quand le prix il fait x 10, voilà, il a
pas augmenté de 10, 20 %, il a augmenté
de euh 900 %. Et donc ça c'est quand
même un des problèmes et pour moi c'est
le principal risque. Alors même si en ce
moment on a euh on a plus de on a des
prix qui ont plutôt baissé, qu'on est
censé avoir aussi des nouveaux terminaux
qui se mettent en place aux États-Unis
et peut-être au Qatar qui fait que
certaines personnes prévoient qu'on va
être noyé sous le gaz naturel. Euh ben
il y a quand même ce risque le le risque
pour moi le plus important c'est quand
même faut être vigilant sur ce qui se
passe sur le gaz naturel parce que une
fois de plus c'est le premier domino de
la crise de l'inflation et donc on
serait bien on ferait faire attention à
ce que ça se reproduise pas c'est
possible on sera pas noyé sous le gaz
mais il y a effectivement des projets en
cours de développement notamment chez
deux des chez les grands exportateurs
mondiaux de GNL à commencer par
États-Unis unis, ensuite Qatar, on
l'évoquait tout à l'heure. Il y a
d'autres pays qui montent en puissance,
le Mozambique, même s'il y a un certain
nombre de problèmes géopolitiques dans
le nord du pays qui ont retardé des
projets, mais ces projets vont se faire.
Il y a de nouveaux acteurs qui arrivent
sur le marché. La le Sénégal, la
Mauritanie ont commencé à exporter du
gaz naturel liquéfié dans les dernières
semaines. Voilà. Donc comme le disait
Philippe, je suis pas très inquiet sur
l'approvisionnement pétrolier,
certainement pas, et gazier
mondial. Ensuite, voilà, c'est ça se
fait pas en appuyant sur un bouton,
hein, ça demande beaucoup de
d'investissement, ça demande le respect
d'un certain nombre de délais, si les
projets ont du retard et cetera. Mais je
suis pas très très inquiet par rapport à
ça. Il y a la question bien sûr du prix
qu'on ne maîtrise pas par définition. Le
pétrole, c'est un marché mondial. Le
gaz, c'était plutôt des marchés
régionaux, mais avec le gaz naturel
niquéfié, évidemment, ça on va quand
même de plus en plus vers un marché
inversal et comme on est très peu
producteur, la France, il faut le
rappeler produit 1 % du pétrol et de gaz
qu'on consomme. On en apporte 99 %. Donc
évidemment, nous ne maîtrisons pas les
prix avec les impacts sur notre balance
commerciale, notre balance des paiements
et d'autres conséquences pour les
consommateurs et pour les industriels.
J'ouvre une question qui n'a rien à voir
peut-être un peu juste après. Oui. On
augmente nos importations de gaz
naturelflié, ces gros frigos, ces
grosses
bonbonnes. Est-ce que les mesures
antiterroristes ou anti-attentat ont été
renforcées en fonction de l'augmentation
? Parce que un un les trois bonbonnes
sur le bateau si ça pète ça non mais
c'est le gaz naturel liquéfié ça pète
pas hein. Ah non non non non c'est c'est
inodore insipide et non explosif. Le gaz
naturel liquéfié il est à - 163°. On
peut jeter une bombe il va se répartir
et il ne il ne va pas se ça ça ça donc
c'est pas très intéressant pour un pour
un terroriste. Euh par l'hydrogène c'est
mieux. Comment ? pas l'hydrogène. Ça
c'est l'hydrogène, c'est
l'hydrogène, c'est c'est beaucoup plus
risqué. Oui, ce que ce que je voulais
dire c'est de rappeler une nouvelle fois
par rapport à à la à la question des
prix, c'est que si on arrêtait
aujourd'hui comme certains écologistes
le le chantent même Jean-Marc
Jeankovici, je suis pas d'accord avec
lui, je suis d'accord souvent avec lui
sur beaucoup de points, sauf qu'il est
des croissantistes et moi pas mais sur
les points techniques, je suis assez
d'accord avec lui. Il expliquait, il
avait publié une tribune dans le avec
Laurence Tobira et Gael Giro si je me
souviens bien expliquant qu'il fallait
arrêter les développements de nouveaux
champs gaziers et pétroliers. Alors ça
si on le fait comme je l'ai dit compte
tenu du déclin naturel des champsers et
pétroliers ça c'est un bon moyen pour
faire exploser les prix avec une rupture
offre demande extrêmement rapide. Donc
ça veut dire qu'il y a rien à faire. Euh
il comme le gaz et le pétrole
continueront à exister dans le mix
énergétique, même s'il baissent
progressivement au cours des des
décennies euh prochaines, ce que je ce
que je pense, il faudra inévitablement
continuer à explorer et à développer des
à développer des champs et donc à
investir là-dedans. Quit à en laisser
dans la terre quand on aura trouvé une
alternative complète au fossiles.
Question internet. Il a été fait mention
à plusieurs reprises que le prix de
l'électricité est indexé sur le gaz. Ce
choix de fixation du prix n'existait pas
il y a 30 ans. En France, le prix était
historiquement fixé par EDF de manière
souveraine. L'une des solutions simples
et rapide qui n'est pas qui n'est que
comptable serait de revenir à l'ancienne
tarification et cela ne gênerait en rien
l'échange d'électricité avec nos
voisins. Pourquoi ne pas le dénoncer ?
Alors, je peux commence mais je
terminerai. Allez, tu tu termineras.
Alors euh oui, c'est vrai que alors
d'abord on est dans un on a créé un
marché. Donc ça veut dire entre
guillemets ce que propose la la personne
euh ça veut dire revenir à un ce qu'on
appelle un monopole naturel qui est euh
qui serait EDF où effectivement EDF
étant à ce moment-là gérant toutes les
sources d'électricité et tout le marché
de l'électricité peut effectivement être
déficit sur certaines
sources bénéficiaires sur d'autres et
donc lisser à un prix constant et rendre
pratiquement invisible le prix du gaz
qui est le prix de la dernière source.
Euh sortir du du système électrique
européen ne changerait rien parce que
vous avez à l'intérieur de la France
plusieurs fournisseurs de
gaz,
plusieurs producteurs de gaz et donc ça
veut dire que globalement si vous voulez
revenir à un EDF initial, c'est ce que
Nicolas appelé les census à un certain
moment. Il a raison d'ailleurs parce que
il n'apporte pas grand-chose et il
provoque parfois des fortes
augmentations de l'électricité. Ça veut
dire que ces gens envers qui on s'est
engagé à les intégrer dans le marché
d'électricité, on leur dit du jour au
lendemain, c'est fini, vous vous
retirez, euh vous avez plus le droit euh
ni à produire ni à bon et en plus c'est
complètement contraire aux règles
européennes. Alors, on peut
effectivement euh contrecarrer et aller
au-delà des règles européennes. Et
enfin, la France a signé un enfin c'est
pas une charte disons à accepter
l'existence d'un d'un marché européen
ouvert de l'électricité. On peut pas
s'en on peut pas s'en s'en retirer comme
ça. Nicolas. Ouais. Alors, je pense que
le c'est un sujet qui est compliqué donc
je vais y aller rapidement mais pas trop
rapidement non plus.
Le système du coût marginal dont on
parle. Donc c'est la dernière centrale
appelée sur le réseau qui fait le coût
et souvent on appelle par coût
croissant. C'est une invention
française. C'est Marcel Boiteteux qui
l'a inventé parce que comme
l'électricité ne se stock pas, il faut
qu'on soit capable de payer tout le
monde. Et donc on était obligé de mettre
en place ce coût marginal pour être sûr
d'avoir le dernier kilow en face de la
demande. Donc ça c'est c'est ce qui est
sur le marché. Sauf qu'avant c'était
marché français et que maintenant on a
un marché européen qui sont finalement
des marchés qui sont interconnectés mais
on reste toujours avec un marché
français, un marché allemand, un marché
et cetera. Et donc il y a deux choses.
Il y a le marché donc ça c'est pour
s'assurer que en temps et en heure on a
toujours l'offre qui est égale à la
demande. Et après, il y a le prix que
paye le
consommateur. Le prix que le paye le
consommateur effectivement avant était
calculé différemment. C'est-à-dire qu'on
prenait les coûts de DF, on rajoutait
une marge et ça faisait le prix pour le
consommateur. Et donc c'est pour ça
qu'on était très proche des coûts euh de
notre parc nucléaire. Et puis les règles
ont changé avec le l'intégration et
l'ouverture du marché européen
l'électricité. C'estàdire qu'on nous a
demandé de changer cette règle et cette
règle, elle a été changée notamment avec
la reine qui fait que on est un des
seuls pays où on avait une exposition
limitée du marché à 30 % dans la facture
puisqu'on a pou négocier auprès de
l'Union européenne que 70 % de la
facture soit du nucléaire. Donc ça
c'était l'arène, sauf que cette arène
avait quelques défauts et que la part de
70 % nucléaire est tombée à 50 à 45 et
quand même donc la part de marché est
montée de 30 à 55 et qu'en même temps
les prix de marché ont été multipliés
par 4. Donc ça fait que la facture des
Français ont été multipliée par 8. Donc,
on doit revenir à une formule qui est
que nous allons payer le coût de notre
parc plus une marge pour les
producteurs. Euh et ça, ça nécessite une
négociation avec la Commission
européenne. Moi ce que j'ai proposé,
mais les Français c'est un sujet qui est
compliqué pour eux, la Rennes c'est une
mauvaise chose. Non, la Ren en fait
c'est ce qu'a fait l'Espagne. Ça nous
permet de nous protéger du marché et de
réduire l'exposition de 100 % à 30 %.
Ben moi, je proposais de l'améliorer en
intégrant l'hydraulique dans ce
mécanisme. Comme ça, l'exposition de
marché passe de 30 % à 20 %. Donc 80 %,
c'est hydraulique et nucléaire. Et en en
corrigeant ce problème lié au sensus
dont tu parlais, on est parlé d'un on
est passé d'un pays qui avait un
fournisseur d'électricité à un pays qui
en a 100. Est-ce qu'on a vraiment besoin
d'avoir 100 fournisseurs d'électricité ?
Ah non non non. 80% qui produisent que
des factures et donc moi je pense que 80
% donc moi je vous ai justement comment
c'est des traders à cha donc moi je
voulais les forcer à produire un minimum
par exemple un/art de ce qu'ils vendent
ils peuvent pas vendre plus de quatre
fois ce qu'ils produisent et là on
enlèverait 80 % des census et donc on en
garderait quelques-uns ça ferait un
petit peu de concurrence mais on
éviterait ce phénomène décrètement qui
concrètement a fait passer la part du
nucléaire de 70 à 45 % de nos factures.
C'est un écrraitement en type décrétage
spéculatif. C'est un écrêtement parce
qu'en fait les fournisseurs alternatifs
avec l'arène en gros on a été attaqué
par des sociétés françaises directie a
attaqué la France auprès de la
commission parce que elle pouvait pas le
marché était pas ouvert à la concurrence
et donc ça a forcé la France et
notamment EDF EDF à vendre un/4 de sa
production nucléaire à ses fournisseurs
alternatifs. un/4 ça faisait 100 TW sauf
qu'ils se sont tellement développés
parce qu'ils n'avaient aucune contrainte
de production que la demande de ces
fournisseurs alternatifs est monté à 150
TW alors qu'ils ont le droit à 100 et
comme ils ont demandé 150 de 100 ben on
leur a dit ben on va écrter et donc vous
allez avoir que 2/ tiers que de ce que
vous demandez et comme vous avez que de
tiers de ce que vous demandez on doit le
refléter dans la facture parce que
l'autre tiers vous allez devoir
l'acheter sur le marché 150 terw ça fait
combien de gas
Gig quoi ? Water. Bah 0,5 1500 Ouais 04.
Ah bah oui non 015 tout ça fait
polytechnique non ?
Et donc et donc et donc ben 2/3 de 70 %
ça fait 45 % et donc c'est pour ça qu'on
est donc en fait on avait cet outil là,
on a préféré ne pas corriger les défauts
et jeter le bébé avec le du bain. Il
fallait à mon avis corriger les défauts
et on pouvait avoir une électricité à 80
% sur nucléaire hydraulique et le 20 %
du marché en fait c'est ça correspond à
la part physique du marché. Le marché on
en a besoin quand ? Bah quand soit quand
on en a trop, soit quand on en a pas
assez. Et donc c'est là où on échange
euh on a 15 GW qu'on échange avec nos
voisins. Euh donc ça c'était la bonne
solution mais pour l'instant c'est pas
ce qui est prévu. Je maintiens 150 TW
c'est 150000 GWh. Oui. Voilà.
Vous êtes sûr là ? Vous êtes euh Ah vous
êtes 1 terw ? Oui, je me suis trompé.
Absolum. Donc 150 TW ça fait combien de
gas ? GW 150000 GW. Il y a 1000 GW dans
1 TW. Ça fait combien de centrales
nucléairire ça ? Alors, une centrale
nucléaire va à peu près produire
annuellement 7 TWh à peu près. Non, non,
12. Tu es à 12 sur Ah oui ou si tuas par
réacteur par réacteur. Ah ouais. Oui. 6
entre 6 et 7. Donc on leur accordé.
L'équivalent de combien de centrales
nucléaire ? 50 25 sur 150
euh 150 divis 150 divis par 7 euh ça
nous fait 2,5 2,5
non non non non ça fait 20
250 TW 25 réacteurs. Comment ? Bref, bon
moi je suis à 15 réacteurs. On est un
peu fatigué là réact à quel point
l'urgence climatique est-elle prise en
compte dans vos propos ? Ah alors ça
c'est Ah benah elle est très prise en
compte dans nos propos puisque avec
Philippe on a proposé la seule solution
qui peut permettre de faire baisser les
émissions euh mondiale de CO2 donc euh
donc on attend d'ailleurs que la qu'elle
soit adoptée à la COP 30 mais euh c'est
la seule solution que je connaisse qui
puisse avoir un impact sur les émissions
mondiales de CO2. Alors moi, je
retournerai la question en disant la
notion d'urgence climatique est quelque
chose d'assez euh d'assez vague. Donc
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire encore une
fois l'urgence climatique ? Est-ce que
ça veut dire que si on ne décarbone pas
instantanément, c'est la fin du monde ?
Non, moi j'y crois pas. Donc je ne suis
moi je suis un climatorisé à faire
l'avocat du diable. Oui, je je suis j'ai
simplement rajouté à ce à ce à cet
auditeur que je suis climato convaincu,
donc j'ai aucun problème. Je suis
convaincu du réchauffement et de son
origine anthropique, mais que par
contre, il y a beaucoup d'indicateurs
qu'on va pas développer ici mais qui
montrent que c'est plutôt un phénomène
qui est, je vais dire qui est
auto régulateur plutôt que euh un
phénomène qui est exponentiel. Il est
logarithmique. Voilà. Donc c'est-à-dire
qu'il a plutôt tendance à diminuer avec
l'augmentation du CO2. C'est quoi la
source ? Oh le GC
sûr. Ah oui. Donc quand ça s'appelle la
formule de mire quand la les Merci pour
le capitaine
Fact. Question. Quand le taux d'humidité
dépasse 90 % et qu'il y a une chaleur
intense de 40°, le taux de mortalité
quand on n'est pas sous la clime, c'est
de combien ?
Ah, le taux de Je ne connais pas le taux
de mortalité. Par contre,
incontestablement, les vagues de chaleur
sont c'est le c'est ce sont les seuls,
je vais dire événements climatiques
actuels qui causent beaucoup de
mortalité. Les autres événements causent
très très peu de très très peu de
mortalité. Mais la mortalité du
important plus une vague de chaleur,
c'est mortel. L'étal, bah c'est pas
l'étal pour tout le monde, c'est l'étal
pour ça peut pour toi, c'est l'étal. pas
bah pas pour moi. Pourquoi pour moi ?
Bah à ton âge si je te mets en Asie du
Sud-Est à 40°gr 95 % de l'humidité Abu
Dhabi non
je je tiens je tiens le coup plus que 25
minutes. Il y a pas de il y a pas de il
y a pas de souci de niveau. Voilà il y a
plein de climatisation aux émirats je
crois à l'intérieur à l'intérieur il
faut un manteau de fourrure pour ces
dames. D'accord. Euh la question c'est
les zones côtières d'Asie du Sud-Est
ultra peuplé sont relativement exposées
à ce type de vague de chaleur ? Ouais.
Puis elle a un peu à la montée des
océans aussi. C'est quand même
inquiétant. Oui. Mais quand on alors
j'ai il y a il y a une base de données
puisque tu demandes souvent des
références, il y a une base de données
qui s'appelle MD data qui reprend en
fait l'ensemble des catastrophes
météorologiques depuis 1970. C'est
reconnu par l'ONU et ça donne le nombre
de victimes et le coût. Et donc quand on
cumule tout ça, on arrive à 01 % de
mortalité et à 01% à 01 point de PIB de
coût. Donc ça veut dire que globalement
quand on nous dit que les vagues de
chaleur vont détruire la moitié de la
population et réduire de moitié le le
pipe mondial, je suis quand même assez
perplexe. Alors c'est vrai que l'avenir
n'est écrit n'est écrit nulle part. Pas
pour moi, mais pas non plus pour les
catastrophistes. Moi, je pense que
malheureusement le
disant l'avenir il est il est devant ou
derrière. Voà. Moi j'ai il y a quelque
chose que j'aime pas trop c'est les
raviolis les brocolis pas que non
je me bat contre l'écoanxiété
en faitalgie j'aime pas j'aime pas trop
qu'on fasse peur aux populations parce
que alors c'est vrai que c'est un très
bon moyen de les contrôler mais en fait
c'est aussi un très bon moyen de nous
faire faire des bêtises donc aujourd'hui
je pense que que ce soit Francis ou
Philippe on est tous d'accord qu'il y a
un changement climatique on est tous
d'accord que qu'il y a les d'origin
trophropique, mais on est aussi tous
d'accord qu'en fait personne ne fait
rien et c'est ça le vrai problème. Et
donc c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui, je
rajoute un peu mais c'est pour ça que
nous on a essayer de trouver une
solution et et moi j'en suis convaincu.
tant qu'on ne fera rien au niveau du
commerce international où finalement on
allit tout fabriquer au charbon en Asie.
Alors c'est bien de c'est bien de de de
faire tout de faire toutes ces petites
contraintes, mais être écranxieux alors
que concrètement rien n'est fait. Enfin,
posez-vous la question, ça fait 30 ans,
on va fêter 30 ans qu'on fait des cops
et on n jamais aimé émis autant de CO2.
Ça fait 30 ans qu'on essaie de les faire
baisser et on en a jamais émis autant.
Est-ce qu'il y a pas un problème
? Nous analysons des tendances, ça ne
veut pas évidemment forcer, ça ne va pas
être interprété comme le fait de dire
changement climatique, ça n'existe pas,
c'est pas important et cetera. Mais
quand on regarde les tendances
énergétiques mondiales, économiques,
démographiques, on se dit que on n'est
pas on n'est pas très bien parti. Les
pays en développement et émergents nous
disent légitimement "Nous voulons voir
notre niveau de vie progresser. Nous
avons donc besoin de consommer plus
d'énergie". Euh les pays développés ne
veulent pas forcément remettre en cause
de façon importante leur niveau de vie.
Leur population ne l'accepterait pas
forcément.
les la décroissance. Bon, un référendum
sur la décroissance, je pense qu'on
aurait pas beaucoup de dans la plupart
des pays du monde, je crois vois pas une
majorité pour ça. Donc voilà, on est sur
des tendances et nous l'avons rappelé en
2024, le monde n'a jamais consommé
autant de pétrole, de charbon et de gaz
naturelle les trois énergies fossiles.
C'est Bakiavel qui disait qu'il a le
monopole de la peur à la domination des
esprits. Donc le
climatocatastrophisme est aussi
largement aujourd'hui instrumentalisé
euh à des fins politiques, hein. Ça fait
pas l'ombre. Ça fait pas l'ombre d'un
doute le dans 20 ans, tu seras peut-être
plus là mais on te racontera. On me
racontera
quand tu me rejoindras. Tu me
raconteras. Exactement. Par rapport à ce
que disait Nicolas, l'écoanxiété. Bon,
on comprend la volonté de de de
personnes, de mouvements, de groupes, de
dirigeants, de dire euh on va vraiment
insister là-dessus pour parce que les
gens vont
bouger. Euh est-ce que quand on est très
anxieux, est-ce qu'on bouge ou est-ce
qu'on est paralysé ? Catatonie
émotionnelle. Non, non, non, non, non,
non. C'est ça le problème. Ou sinon
sinon, on peut voir ça chez des hommes
politiques, ils sont hyper actifs,
de gaz.
Il y a un point sur lequel on c'est
intéressant. Alors ça sort complètement
de l'énergie mais je pense qu'on
investit aujourd'hui beaucoup trop dans
la transition au sens de l'atténuation,
c'est-à-dire la donc investir dans la
baisse des émissions, qu'on investit pas
qu'oninvestit pas du tout dans ce qu'on
appelle l'adaptation. Donc c'est-à-dire
qu'en fait le réchauffement climatique,
il est là, il va nous demander un
certain nombre certain nombre
d'adaptations. Euh donc ça veut dire que
l'eau, il y en a toujours autant hein
quand on nous dit il y a plus d'eau ou
alors la voisier va se retourner dans sa
tombe, hein. Rien ne se perd, rien ne se
crée. Voilà. Mais par contre euh bon,
l'eau est redistribuée de différentes
façons. Je crois que c'est Serge Zarka,
je me demande si tu l'as pas invité une
fois une fois le bonjour. Un jour, on
lui passe le bonjour, qui expliquait bah
qu'aujourd'hui euh les courgettes
poussent à Orléan et les poischiches
poussent à peau. Ben ça veut dire
qu'effectivement faut pas seulement
revoir notre modèle énergétique,
peut-être faut-il aussi revoir notre
modèle alimentaire. Et il ne faut pas
demander seulement ça aux agriculteurs,
il faut demander ça aussi aux
consommateurs parce que si les
consommateurs ne changent pas de mode de
consommation, les agriculteurs ne
changeront pas. Si les modes si les
consommateurs ne changent pas de mode de
consommation d'énergie, bah les
producteurs, ils continueront à produire
du pétrole et du gaz. Et qu'est-ce qu'on
dit aux africains ? La bande saélienne,
qu'est-ce qu'on dit ? À quel Qu'est-ce
qu'on leur dit ? On leur dit faites
pousser des courgettes, des pois chiches
ou manger du sable.
Bah alors là
alors
là ton raisonnement touche à sa fin là
quand même. Non. Oui mais tu
l'adaptation
l'adaptation tout toute toute toute
contrée toute contrée permet de
s'adapter. Les gens ne vivent pas non
plus tous au milieu du SAR. Donc il y a
des oasis quand même non ? L'accord de
Paris COP
21 euh décembre 2015, c'est deux mots
clés que Philippe a rappelé atténuation,
lutte contre les émissions,
adaptation. Euh dans l'accord de Paris,
les deux concepts sont mis sur le même
plan et ce qui à mon avis est assez
juste parce que le changement
climatique, il est déjà là. On peut dire
il faut pas s'adapter parce que sinon on
reconnaît que le changement climatique
est là mais il est là donc il faut bien
s'adapter. C'est une question de très
importante y compris de survie pour
certaines populations. Alors, par
rapport à l'Afrique euh quand on regarde
l'ensemble du continent
africain, il y a plusieurs pays
africains qui dans les dernières années,
disons depuis 2022, pour ne pas aller
très loin et dans les prochaines années
sont devenus deviennent vont devenir des
pays producteurs et exportateurs
d'hydrocarbure. Mozambique gaz novembre
2022.
Sénégal pétrole juin 2024 Sénégal
Mauritanie gaz naturel liquéfié
exportation production début 2025
l'Oganda producteur de pétrole
exportateur en 2026 la Namibie vers 2030
pour le gaz Tanzani probablement vers
2030 donc ces pays-là qui sont pourtant
parmi les plus vulnérables au changement
climatique le message qu'il nous envoie
nous avons pour certains d'entre nous la
chance c'est ce qu'ils disent he d'avoir
des énergies fossiles dans notre
sous-sol. Cette chance, nous allons
l'exploiter que vous le vouliez ou non.
Et il faudra pas nous opposer le
changement climatique pour penser qu'on
va renoncer à exploiter nos ressources
souveraineté. Alors, on peut trouver ce
discours complètement discutable, mais
qui va les empêcher de le faire ? Et ça
se passe aussi en Afrique, pas seulement
en Amérique du Nord ou en Chine qui le
font aussi gément bien sûr comme on l'a
vu, et avec Donald Trump de plus en
plus. Mais voilà, c'est aussi dans des
pays en développement, des pays
africains où on se dit les pays
développés et bien une partie de leur
richesse, ils le doivent à une très
importante consommation d'énergie
fossile. Nous, on veut aller pas
forcément au même niveau, mais on veut
aller dans la même direction et par
conséquent si on en a dans notre
sous-sol, on va l'exploiter. On va
essayer de faire ça le plus
intelligemment possible, mais faudra pas
nous dire climat et on s'arrête de
développer notre pétrole et notre gaz.
Et là-dedans, le beau clé, c'est notre
ça nous appartient. C'est notre
souveraineté pour l'instant. C'est notre
dé. On va leur rapporter la démocratie
comme on a fait un peu partout au
Moyen-Orient. Ce sera un peu le nôtre.
En plus, on est assez mal placé pour
nous qui avons notre développement
économique et notre développement social
à reposer, il faut jamais l'oublier, sur
les hydrocarbures. On est assez mal
placé pour leur pour leur faire la leçon
de ce côté-là. On arrive à la fin de
notre interview. Vous allez me
conseiller chacun trois livres et un
conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Donc, on fait soit les trois livres et
le conseil, soit les trois livres et
puis le conseil.
Nicolas, trois livres à conseiller.
Trois livres, je vais être très
original. Je vais en faire deux pour le
prix d'un déjà. J'allais proposer la la
dernière BD de Philip Wix ressources
mais qui est excellente et que je vous
recommande mais je pense que son livre
fondateur qu'il faut avoir lu c'est
l'âge des lotch puisque l'âge des lotch
c'est pour moi la suite d'un livre qui
m'a aussi marqué qui s'appelle le
rapport du club de Rome mais qui donne
les solutions. Donc ça c'est le premier.
Après, il y en a un second que je je
suis en train de lire, j'ai j'ai du mal
à trouver du temps, mais qui
s'appelle Les autres ne pensent pas
comme nous. Et malheureusement, j'aurais
du mal à vous dire l'auteur montagne.
Voilà. Exactement. Donc ça c'est quand
même très intéressant. Exactement. Qui a
été au cœur du pouvoir pendant assez
longtemps. Souhirac. Exactement. Et qui
nous donne un peu quelques clés de
lecture qui me qui me manquait. Donc et
comme j'ai pas fini le livre, je vais
encore en apprendre. Et puis un dernier
plus de circonstances que je suis en
train de finir qui est bienvenue en
économie de guerre David Valrez David
Bavrez. C'est pas trop long à lire et
c'est plutôt intéressant et une grille
de lecture je pense qu'il est bon
d'avoir bon d'avoir en tête et conseil
pour les jeunes générations comme ça
j'enchaîne. Alors j'aurais pu dire posez
votre téléphone après l'émission et
prenez un livre mais je vais aussi en
faire deux pour le prix d'un. Mais non,
je je vais m'adresser à tous ceux qui
sont écoranxieux. Je pense que ça sert à
rien d'être écoanxieux et que il vaut
mieux il vaut mieux être dans l'action
et de voir de quelle manière vous pouvez
contribuer à votre façon améliorer les
choses. Mais je pense que l'écoanxiété
effectivement
paralyse et elle vous met pas dans une
posture pour agir. Donc donc donc
oubliez les coanxiétés. Philippe, trois
livres que vous conseiller. Alors trois
livres. Bah d'abord, j'ai beaucoup aimé
les illusionnistes de Géraldine Vosner
et Johann Sek. Donc qui effectivement
explique un peu
l'illusion que nous font entrevoir les
écologistes. Alors ça ne parle pas que
d'énergie, ça parle aussi beaucoup
d'agriculture. Un deuxième livre que
j'ai beaucoup aimé, c'est Rien n'est
joué de Jacques Lecte. Alors, c'est un
livre sur le catastrophisme à travers
les âges. Et en fait, c'est assez
intéressant parce qu'il nous montre que
à travers les âges depuis Nostradamus,
tous les tous les catastrophistes se
sont toujours plantés de A à Z. Euh et
donc ça fait réfléchir sur effectivement
les collapsologues qui nous
annoncent la la fin de la vie sur terre
dans 10 ans comme le fait régulièrement
Yv Cochet par exemple.
Et le troisème livre que je vous
conseille, c'est le livre de
Jean-Paulouri qui s'appelle de Lia à Ga
où il explique effectivement
la disons la l'excès d'un côté de la
technologie et le retour à GAA et la
supériorité de GAA sur la race humaine
de l'autre que considèrent les que
considèrent les écologistes. Après, je
vais quand même en rajouter un 4è, c'est
le mien qui s'appelle les 10 commandes.
C'est interdit. Ah bon ? Les 10
commandements de la transition
énergétique. Voilà. Juste une précision
de la communauté. Attention à la
confusion. Oui, le forçage radiatif du
gaz carbonique augmente logarith
logarithm logarithmiqu.
Oui, logarithmiquement.
Merci. Formule 1998 reprise par le GC.
Mais ça ne veut pas dire que le
réchauffement ralentit ou s'autorégule.
Le GC précise au contraire que les
réroactions amplifie le réchauffement.
Donc non, le climat n'est pas
autorégulé. C'est une mauvaise
interprétation scientifique.
Alors euh je donc le donc il la personne
reprend bien le comment dirais-je le la
la formule de mire qui est qui est
logarithmique mais la personne peut
regarder les courbes du JC avec
rétroaction climatique. Elles sont aussi
logarithmiques quand on rajoute.
C'est-à-dire que la formule de mire
n'est que l'effet direct du CO2 via le
forçage radiatif comme il rajoute les
trois courbes de de
rétraction climatique, celle à 10, 50 et
90, donc la courbe basse, la courbe
moyenne et la courbe haute, on peut
vérifier qu'elles ont aussi tendance à à
s'écraser, qu'elles sont donc bien
logarithmiques.
Francis, trois livres, un conseil pour
les jeunes génération. Et si avant tes
trois livres, si tu as un sujet que tu
souhaites aborder, qu'on a oublié,
fais-toi plaisir. Euh merci. Alors, je
vais tricher un petit peu pour les
livres. Ce ne seront pas des livres, ce
seront des rapports et ça se lit.
Euh c'est pas forcément aussi
passionnant que ce que l'on a évoqué et
je pourrais reprendre plusieurs
suggestions mais
euh si vous vous intéressez à la
prospective énergétique dans une idée de
long terme, lisez les perspectives
énergétiques mondiales de l'AIE, agence
interale de l'énergie basée à Paris, de
l'OPEP, l'Organisation des pays
exportateurs de pétrole Vienne et du
département de l'énergie des États-Unis,
Washington et vous aurez déjà trois
points de vue différents, ce qui est
toujours intéressant sur la même
thématique et ça ça vaut la peine d'être
lu. Mon conseil, tu as pas donné ton
conseil finalement. Oui oui, c'est vrai.
Ah alors mon conseil, moi c'est que je
je l'ai dit hein, je reste un un
irréductible défenseur du développement
humain et donc je considère que la
transition énergétique ne se fera pas
sans production de richesse et donc la
décroissance est un est une solution
sans avenir. Voilà.
Mon conseil pour la jeune génération,
l'énergie c'est un enjeu
essentiel sur le plan de la souveraineté
des nations, sur le plan économique,
industriel, social, environnemental et
c'est un enjeu
démocratique. Donc il faut s'en occuper
et ne pas laisser ça seulement aux
experts et aux politiques. Politiques.
Messieurs, merci. Merci. Merci à vous.
[Musique]